MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA
ATKINS BATES BAKER FOR JUST
BRADFORD CABALLERO CORTESE
DALLY DODD DORADO EGGMAN GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROVE HERTZBERG HUESO
FURTADO JONES KAMLAGER LAYERED
LEYVA THE MON MCGUIRE MELENDEZ
MEN NEWMAN NIELSEN A CHOI BO
PAM PORTANTINO ROCK RUBIO
SKINNER. TURN ON BURKE WHITE
HOUSE SCHEME WIENER WELL.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
SENATOR LARRY. WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING WE WILL BE LED
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG I SENATOR WIENER.
LOVING AND MERCIFUL CREATOR. AS
YOUR SENATORS CONCLUDE THEIR
WORK TODAY. MAY THEY RECOGNIZE
THAT THIS YEAR EACH ONE HAS
BEEN A PROTECTOR FOR THOSE
WITHOUT PROTECTION. A GUIDE FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE LOST THEIR WAY.
A SHIP FOR THOSE WITH OCEANS TO
CROSS. A BRIDGE FOR THOSE WITH
REVERSED ACROSS. A SANCTUARY
FOR THOSE IN DANGER. A LAMP FOR
THOSE WITHOUT LIGHT. A PLACE OF
REFUGE FOR THOSE WHO LACK
SHELTER. AND A SERVANT TO ALL
IN THE- I THEIR SUMMER BE
BLESSED WITH THE REST AND
RELAXATION. A MAN. CALIPHATE'S
ARMY IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA AND TO THE
REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT STANDS
ONE NATION UNDER GOD. WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION OUR
FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS WILL BE
CONSIDERATION OF THE BUDGET
BILL PACKAGE BUT BEFORE WE
PROCEED WE WILL MOVE TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS FOR PROCEDURAL
PURPOSES A MAN ASK EVERYBODY TO
PLEASE COME IN SIT DOWN. SO-THAT WE CAN- SPEEDILY GET TO
OUR ORDER OF BUSINESS TODAY
SENATOR SKINNER IS PREPARED FOR
HER PROCEDURAL MOTION. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS. BY
MOVED TO SUSPEND THE SENATE
RULES AS THEY RELATE TO
ASSEMBLY BILLS. ONE SIXTY FOUR
ONE THIRTY ONE ONE THIRTY TO
ONE THIRTY THREE ONE THIRTY
FIVE ONE FORTY ONE FORTY FOUR
ONE FORTY EIGHT. ONE FIFTY
THREE ONE FIFTY SIX AND ONE
SIXTY AND I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. WHAT I'M SAYING SENATOR
WORK TAKING ON PRESIDENT- I
OBJECT TO THE MOTION AND THEN
ASK FOR A ROLL CALL VOTE.
SENATOR SKINNER ASPIRIN I WROTE
SENATOR WILK ASTRONOVA. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
NO BACKER. FIVE BORJAS NO
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
CORTESE. I DALLY. NO DODD I
DRAWS I EGGMAN. I GLAZER. HI
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG
FIVE WITH SO. HER TADO. JONES.
KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE LEYVA. I
LIMóN. MCGUIRE FIVE MELENDEZ
NO MAN. I NEWMAN I NIELSEN.
OTOBO NO HAN. I PORTANTINO I
ROTH FIVE RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN AYE I'M BURKE I Y. CASKEY
I WIENER AYE WILK. NO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE
HUESO WELL HER TADO. JONES NO
YEAH LIMóN. NIELSEN HIS TWENTY
EIGHT KNOWS SEVEN THE MOTION
PASSES. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
BUDGET BILLS FIRST ITEM WE WILL.
START WITH IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTY FOUR. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
SIXTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TANG AN ACT RELATING TO THE
STATE BUDGET AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BUDGET BILL
CENTER SKINNER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS. WHAT WE ARE DOING
TODAY IS AN ACTING THE TRAILER
BILLS THAT WILL. ALLOW THAT
BUDGET BILL SB ONE TWENTY NINE
WHICH WE PASSED IN THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED ON MONDAY. TO BE FULLY
EFFECTIVE AND THAT THE
APPROPRIATIONS AND EXPENDITURES
THAT WE AUTHORIZED WILL HAVE
THE APPROPRIATE STATUTES
ANOTHER RULES IN PLACE TO BE
ABLE TO ACHIEVE THE GOALS FOR
WHICH WE SAT. AND LET ME REMIND
YOU BEFORE I GO THROUGH THIS
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR WHICH IS THE
FIRST ONE ON OUR FILE THAT THAT
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET.
WHICH WE HAVE NOW ENACTED.
FUNDS ARE K. THROUGH TWELVE
SCHOOLS AND CHILD CARE AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL EVER. IT SETS A
PATH TO DEBT FREE COLLEGE FOR
OUR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS IT PUTS
ADDITIONAL STIMULUS CHECKS
DIRECTLY INTO THE HANDS OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES. PROVIDES
MORE GRANT FUNDS TO OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES IN OUR NON PROFITS
IN OUR ARTS INSTITUTIONS. AND
IT MAKES TRANSFORMATIVE
INVESTMENTS TO REDUCE HUNGER
AND HOMELESSNESS IN OUR STATE.
AND A VERY SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN STATEWIDE
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH
WILL ALL TALK ABOUT LATER FANS
THIS SCHOOL YEAR CALIFORNIA
WILL BECOME THE FIRST STATE
EVER TO PROVIDE FREE SCHOOL
MEALS TO OUR K. THROUGH TWELVE
STUDENTS. SO HE BILL BEFORE US
NOW IS ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
BUDGET ACT WHICH WAS SIGNED ON
MONDAY. AND IT PROVIDES THE-
FIRST. FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION
OUT OF THE THREE FIVE YEAR
TOTAL OF SIX BILLION FOR THE
BROADBAND INVESTMENT THAT WE'RE
MAKING. AND IT REMOVES EIGHT
MILLION THAT WAS PROVIDED TO
SUPPORT I H. S. S. RECIPIENTS
WITH MEDI CAL REDETERMINATION.
BECAUSE THE BINDER FUNDING IS
NO LONGER NEEDED SINCE WE ARE
DOING WE ARE NOT DOING THE
AUTOMATION THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY
ENVISIONED WHAT MAKES OTHER
CONFORMING TECHNICOLOR
CLARIFYING CHANGES AND WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM CENTER
BATES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT JUST A QUESTION OF
THE AUTHOR- I HAVE A CARE
THROUGH THERE ON A PORTION OF
THE DEAL SENATOR THAT REMOVES
THE PUBLIC CONTRACT
TRANSPARENCY REQUIREMENTS ON A
THERE'S A THREE MILLION DOLLAR
STUDY ON PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE READY NOTHIN IT
ALSO IS PERMITTING- DPH. TO
ENTER INTO A FIVE YEARS FULL
FOURTH CONTRACT ON CHILDHOOD
TRAUMA PREVENTION YEAH AND IT
IS ALWAYS A CONCERN I THINK OF
PUBLIC OFFICIALS THAT. REMOVING
THE COMPETITIVE BID PROCESS
FROM CONTRACTS YOU KNOW COULD
RAISE ISSUES ARE CERTAINLY
POTENTIALLY WERE A WASTE OF
RESOURCES WE'VE HAVE THAT
CERTAINLY HERE IS ME MADAM
PRESIDENT I CANNOT HEAR THE
QUESTION. THE QUESTION IS I
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THE
RATIONALE THAT WAS USED TO
REMOVE THE ODDS. OF PUBLIC
CONTRACTING TRANSPARENCY
REQUIREMENTS THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN
MORE OF A STANDARD HAND OFF.
STATE AND CERTAINLY GOVERNMENT
CONTRACTS. CENTER SKINNER WOULD
YOU TO PUT UP PRESENT THAT
INFORMATION IN YOUR CLOSING-
CERTAINLY IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ONE THING THEN WE'RE AT
YOUR CLOSING CENTER SKINNER
THANK YOU- THE SPACE THE
QUESTION YOU ASKED THERE THIS
PARTICULAR BUDGET BILL HAS SOME
TECHNICAL- CLARIFYING CHANGES
IN THE ANALYSIS WOULD OUTLINE.
WHY THAT PARTICULAR ASPECT WAS
NEEDED BUT MOST OF THESE ARE
PRO FORMA BECAUSE OF OTHER
ACTIONS THAT WE TOOK AND IN
ORDER TO MAKE THAT CONSISTENCY.
THING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES AYE BAKER. I FORGES I
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I CORTES
HE- FIVE DALLY I DODD FIVE
TORONTO I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG HI
HUESO HI HURTADO. I JONES I
KAMLAGER I LAYERED I LEYVA AYE
LIMóN I MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ.
MAN I NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN. A
CHIRLA BOTH I PAN I PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN I AM BERG I LIKE OWSKI I
WIENER AYE WILK HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE
MELENDEZ. NIELSEN. I THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING AYE AYE FILE ITEM
NUMBER FORTY FOUR IT IS A
BUDGET BILL MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
THIRTY ONE BY THE ASSEMBLY MANY
ON BUDGET AN ACT RELATING TO
CHILD DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS AND
MAKING APPROPRIATION THEREFORE
TO TAKE FOR ME TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. CENTER SKINNER THE
FORGERS. THANK YOU. SKEWS ME
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I HOPE
YOU HAVE BEEN. I ANTICIPATING
WITH EXCITEMENT THIS TRAILER
BILL AS I HAVE. THIS IS OUR
CHILD CARE AND DEVELOPMENT
TRAILER BILL MOST SIGNIFICANTLY
WHAT THIS BILL DOES. IS THAT IT
PROVIDES RATE INCREASES FOR ALL
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS NOT ONLY
THOSE WHO ARE PART OF THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING UNIT. FOR
WHICH THE AGREEMENT THAT WAS
MET IS ALSO INCLUDED IN THIS
TRAILER BILL BUT ALSO THOSE.
WHO ARE NOT. AND IT FOLLOWS
THAT READING CREASE FOLLOWS THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE STUDY THAT
HAS BEEN CONDUCTED- IT ALSO
WAVES THE CHILD CARE FAMILY
FEES FOR THIS UPCOMING BUDGET
YEAR. AND IT INCREASES THE
NUMBER OF. PLACEMENTS FOR TO
HELP FAMILIES GET CHILD CARE
WHO OTHERWISE MIGHT NOT BE ABLE
TO AFFORD IT AND AS WE KNOW SO
MANY FAMILY MEMBERS PRIMARILY
MOTHERS BUT OTHERS HAVE NOT YET
RETURNED TO WORK BECAUSE THEY
ARE HAVING TO CARE FOR FAMILY
MEMBERS. AND THERE ARE OTHER.
TRAILER BILLS THAT WE ARE GOING
TO BE DEALING WITH TODAY THAT
PROVIDE OTHER SUPPORT THAT WILL
ALLOW PEOPLE WHO ARE NOW HOME
TAKING CARE OF FAMILY MEMBERS
BECAUSE OF INTERRUPTIONS THAT
OCCUR DURING THE PANDEMIC BUT
THIS ONE IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE KNOW. THAT%
WOMEN LEFT THE WORKPLACE IN THE
LARGEST NUMBER AND IT IS THESE
CHILD CARE EXPANSION AND THE
PROVISION OF THE RATE INCREASES
THAT WILL ALLOW THEM TO COME
BACK TO WORK. AND THEN IT ALSO-
INSURERS CONTINUED PROGRESS ON
CHILD CARE REIMBURSEMENT RATE
REFORM BY ESTABLISHING A RATE
REFORM WORK GROUP- WITH DIVERSE
STAKEHOLDER REPRESENTATION THAT
WILL COME BACK OBVIOUSLY IN
VICE CHAIR OF THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
BEEN HARD. FOUGHT BY THE
WOMEN'S POCKETS AS WELL AS THE
STATE SENATE AND VERY- PROUD
THAT WE HAVE IT BEFORE US TODAY
AND URGED HER AYE VOTE. SENATOR
LEYVA. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS TRAILER BILL I WANT TO SAY
TO OUR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS WE
SEE YOU WE HEAR YOU WE RESPECT
YOU AND WE THANK YOU YOU ARE
RAISING OUR FUTURE LEADERS THIS
BILL IS HISTORIC WE'RE PUTTING
MORE MONEY INTO CHILD CARE THAN
WE EVER HAVE I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO ALL MY COLLEAGUES
WHO HAVE PUT UP WITH ME TALKING
ABOUT RATE REFORM FOR THE LAST
THREE YEARS. AND RATE REFORM
ISN'T EASY WHAT WE WERE
REIMBURSING OUT WAS 75% OF THE
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN RATES OF
THINK ABOUT THAT FIVE YEARS OLD
NOW WE WILL BE REIMBURSING 75%
OF THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN OR
MORE WITH MONEY TO HELP MAKE
SURE THAT'S EVEN MORE MONEY TO
OUR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS AND
YOU YOU ASK WHAT DOES THIS DO
FOR OUR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS.
THIS ALLOWS THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
WORKING ON OUR CHILD CARE
pMOST PRECIOUS THINGS OUR
CHILDREN OUR GRANDCHILDREN IT
ALLOWS THOSE HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS TO PAY CLOSE TO A
LIVING WAGE SO WE HAVE WORK TO
DO THERE ARE A HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND SLOTS. INCREASE TO TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND OVER FIVE
YEAS BUT I JUST WANT TO REMIND
PEOPLE THAT JUST L. A. COUNTY
AND SAN MARINO COUNTY ALONE.
NEED A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THOUSAND SLOTS. SO WE HAVE WORK
TO DO BUT WE SHOULD ALL
CELEBRATE WHAT HAS HAPPENED
TODAY ENCOURAGING I WROTE AND I
THINK EVERYONE AND I REALLY
WANT TO THINK THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS. BECAUSE LONG BEFORE I
WAS EVER HERE IN THE SENATE
THEY HAVE BEEN CHAMPIONING
CHILD CARE. CHILD CARE RATES
CHILD CARE SLOTS FOR WITH A
CONGRATULATIONS TO THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS WE DID REALLY WELL THIS
YEAR. AND I HOPE THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO WELL BY THESE
PEOPLE THESE WOMEN. WHO ARE
TAKING CARE OF OUR MOST
PRECIOUS PEOPLE OUR CHILDREN
BIG YARDS AND I BOTH. SENATOR
EGGMAN. BUT THANK YOU- MADAM
PRESIDENT I ALSO JUST WANT TO
RISE VERY BRIEFLY IN JUST THIS
REMARK ON THIS REMARKABLE
HISTORIC- THING WE'RE ABLE TO
DO HERE- LX LIKE SOME OF YOU
I'M I'M A WORKING MOM AND I HAD
TO JUGGLE AND DROP MY KID OFF
THIS MORNING AND DO ALL THAT
AND TRY TO GET TO WORK ON TIME.
AND THAT IS YOU KNOW NOT
KNOWING MY CAR STARTS AND
KNOWING I HAVE GAS AND KNOWING
I HAVE A SAFE PLACE TO TAKE MY
CHILD SO I MEAN WHAT WE'RE
DOING FOR PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW ESPECIALLY ARE
WORKING CLASS WOMEN OF COLOR IS
JUST INCREDIBLE I THINK TO BE
ABLE TO INCREASE THE SLOTS AND
IS A FORMER CHAIR OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS ALSO JUST THANK
AND ACKNOWLEDGE THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS FOR ALL THAT THE
DEDICATION AND WORK. OVER THE
YEARS THAT WE PUT INTO TRYING
TO INCREASE THE SLOTS AND ALSO
INCREASING THE REIMBURSEMENT
RATE BECAUSE WE KNOW IT DOES NO
GOOD TO PROVIDE CHILD CARE FOR
KIDS THE MOMS AND GO BACK TO
WORK IN FOR MAKING OUR
PROVIDERS LIVE IN POVERTY
THEMSELVES SO I JUST WANNA
CONGRATULATE EVERYBODY WHO DID
ALL OF THIS WORK- AND JUST
REALLY NOTE THAT THE HISTORIC
NATURE OF WHAT WE'RE DOING TO
INVEST IN OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS AND OUR FUTURE
LEADERS THANK YOU. SENATOR
BAKER. THANK YOU ARTS WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO. RISE AND PUT
THIS. IN PERSPECTIVE THANKS TO
THE WORK FOR THE CENTER FROM
CHINO CENTER FROM BERKELEY
EMINEM PRO TEM. THIS IS TRULY A
HISTORIC BILL AND- HI AT FRAN
ADVOCATES GOT MORE THINK SUMS
IT UP HE SAID THIS WILL PUT.
CALIFORNIA WILL BECOME THE BEST
STATE IN THE NATION TO RAISE A
CHILD FULL STOP THE BEST
STATION STATE IN THE NATION TO
RAISE A CHILD EVERY CHILD. ONE
YEAR PRE K. MOST WELCOME
CHILDREN GET LEAST TWO YEARS OF
PRE K. PLUS THERE'S A STARK
INCREASE IN INFANT TODDLER
CARE. AND WITH THIS MEASURE
TODAY WE GET OUR HARD WORKING
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
WORKFORCE A STEP TOWARDS A
PROFESSIONAL WAYS THEY DESERVE
IN MY DISTRICT ALONG WITH ME TO
THIRTY PERCENT. INCREASE IN
SALARY FOR THESE WORKERS WE
DEPEND ON TO GET A WIN AND GET
OUR FAMILIES BACK TO WORK. AND
I'M JUST GRATEFUL FOR ALL THIS
AT WORK FOR THIS INCREDIBLE
MEASURE THANK YOU. THINK NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CENTER SKINNER YOU MAKE UP
CENTER KAMLAGER. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF- THIS BUDGET BILL AB
ONE THIRTY ONE AND YOU KNOW I
JUST HAVE TO SAY IT'S ABOUT
TIME- YOU KNOW PARENTS. WORK
ALL KINDS OF HOURS THEY HAVE
ALL KINDS OF JOBS SOME OF THEM
HAVE ALL NUMBERS OF JOBS AND
THEY HAVE CHILDREN OF ALL AGES
AND THAT CONSTELLATION OF
PARENTING REALITY IS WHY WE
NEED A MIX DELIVERY SYSTEM. AND
IT'S WHY WE NEED TO SUPPORT OUR
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS THAT ARE
LICENSE EXAM THAT OUR FAMILY
CHILD CARE HOMES THAT ARE
CENTERS. CHILD CARE KEEPS
CALIFORNIA WORKING AND PARENTS
ARE NOT WORKING. AND THEY'RE
WORRIED ABOUT THEIR CHILDREN.
IN PRODUCTIVITY IS STALLED. AND
IF WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO
HARNESS. THE INNOVATION AND THE
PRODUCTIVITY AND THE DRIVE THAT
HAS COME TO DEFINE CALIFORNIA.
THEN WE SHOULD BE. WAITING WITH
BATED BREATH TO VOTE AYE ON
THIS BILL AND CONTINUING TO
DOUBLE DOWN ON CHILD CARE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR LIMON. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
A BILL THAT ALLOWED OUR CHILD
CARE WORKERS AT TO THE
BARGAINING TABLE AND THAT WAS A
BILL THAT CAME AFTER DCADES
AND DECADES OF ATTEMPTS AND-
ALSO THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS NEVER
STOPPED PUSHING- FOR DECADES
AND DECADES AS A MOTHER OF A IN
FANS WHO IS ON A SEVEN WAIT
LIST IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
FOR CHILD CARE CENTERS I KNOW
THIS ISSUE IN A VERY DEEP AND
PERSONAL WAY AND I KNOW THAT
MANY MANY FAMILIES UNDERSTAND
THAT CHILD CARE IS THE VEHICLE
TO ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE
WE ARE ABLE TO GO TO WORK. AND
SO THIS IS AN IMPORTANT A
HISTORIC BILL AND I DON'T WANT
IT LOST ON US THAT IT'S BEEN
DECADES IN THE MAKING BEYOND
OUR TIME IN THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE EVEN THE BILL THAT WE
AUTHOR THAT I AUTHORED AB TO
ENSURE THAT HEALTHCARE WORKERS
HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
AT THE BARGAINING TABLE UP WITH
A BILL THAT MANY- AUTHORED
PRIOR TO ME AND WE WERE NOT
SUCCESSFUL IN GETTING A
INCLUDING OUR PRO TEM SO I
THINK THAT TODAY'S A BILL IS A
HISTORIC ONE AND IS AT MANY
YEARS IN THE MAKING AND I WANT
TO THANK EVERYONE WHO'S BEEN
INVOLVED IN SUPPORTING. THIS
EFFORT- AND EVERYONE ALSO
RECOGNIZES THAT IT'S HISTORIC
BUT IT DOESN'T SOLVE THE FULL
CALIFORNIA PROBLEM WE STILL
HAVE THE NEED FOR MANY MORE
HUNDREDS OF HOUSING CHILD CARE
SLOTS WE HAVE THE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT OUR CHILD CARE
WORKERS WHO ARE PREDOMINANTLY
WOMEN OF COLOR ARE PAID A
SALARY THAT IS COMMENSURATE TO
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE SPACE-
AND WE STILL HAD THE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE THINK OF
CHILD CARE- BEYOND A BABY
SITTING OPPORTUNITY THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS A
CRITICAL DEVELOPMENT TIME- AND
THEIR ROLE IN A CHILD'S LIFE.
IS CRITICAL AND IMPORTANT. SO
WITH THAT I HOPE THAT WE ALL
THE HI. ANY FURTHER TO. OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. THING MAN
CENTER SKINNER YOU MAY CONCLUDE
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. I AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS
AYE BATES AYE BAKER FIVE FOR
JUST. BRADFORD FIVE CABALLERO
HI CORTES THREE FIVE DALLY.
DODD FIVE TORONTO I EGGMAN I
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ. I GROW.
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. HI FURTADO
I JONES. KAMLAGER I LAYERED HI
LEYVA AYE LIMóN AYE MCGUIRE
FIVE MELENDEZ. MAN I NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN BY A SHOW OF BOTH. I
PAN AYE PORTANTINO HI ROB I
RUBIO I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
AMBERG AYE AYE CASKEY AYE
WIENER AYE WILK. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. FOR JUST.
DALLY GROVE. JONES MELENDEZ
WILK. FIVE THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON
MEMBERS TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FORTY FIVE ANOTHER BUDGET BELT
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY TWO BY
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND ACT RELATING TO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION A MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR SKINNER
THE FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU-
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
THIS IS OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
TRAILER BILL AND IT DOES AGAIN
SOME VERY SIGNIFICANT THINGS
INCLUDING A VERY A LARGE
EXPANSION OF FINANCIAL AID
INCLUDING ALLOWING CAL GRANTS
TO BE ELIGIBLE TO OUR- TWO
STUDENTS WHO ARE RETURNING TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WE HAD A
RESTRICTION ON CAL GRANT SO
THAT IF YOU WERE HAD. A NUMBER
OF YEARS PAST HIGH SCHOOL YOU
ARE OVER A CERTAIN AGE WHEN YOU
RETURN TO A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
EITHER IN ORDER TO GET THAT A
DEGREE OR TO INCREASE YOUR JOB
SKILLS YOU COULD NOT BE
SUPPORTED BY OUR CAL GRANT
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAM. THIS
EXPERIENCE THAT ELIGIBILITY
ALLOWS AND RECOGNIZES THAT OUR
ECONOMY IS CHANGING DIFFERENT
SECTORS ARE NOW THE ONES THAT
REALLY HAVE THE JOB GROWTH AND
THE AND MANY PEOPLE NEED TO
RETURN. WE CAN IMPROVE THOSE
JOB SKILLS IT ALSO PROVIDES.
GIVE ME CAL GRANTS TO STUDENTS
WHO ARE FORMER FOSTER YOUTH.
ALLOWING IT TO COVER NON
TUITION COSTS AND EXPANDS.
CALIFORNIA'S UNIQUE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM TO
HELP COVER THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE AT OUR UC AND CSU
SYSTEMS. WHICH WILL ALLOW MANY
MORE OF OUR FAMILIES TO NOT
HAVE TO RELY ON CITY LARGE
STUDENT LOAN DEBTS- THERE'S
OTHER GREAT THINGS IN THIS BILL
BUT I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. IN
SOME CENTER NEARBY IN. I HAVE
THAT MEMBERS OF THE DESK. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE REACH PLEASE
READ THE AMENDMENTS AMENDMENTS
BY SENATOR NIELSEN STUCK ONE.
BARBARA THE LADYDOWN THE
SENATE THESE AMENDMENTS I AND I
THINK THAT IT IS AN OVERSIGHT.
BUT THESE AMENDMENTS WOULD
INCLUDE THE SCHOOL FOR THE DEAF
AND SCHOOL FOR THE BLIND. ALSO
BEING ELIGIBLE FOR THE FUNDS.
BOTH OF THESE SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN
IN EFFECT. CALIFORNIA SINCE THE
MID EIGHTEEN FIFTIES AND I
BELIEVE THAT THEY SHOULD BE
THEN. ELIGIBLE AND THAT'S
SIMPLY WHAT THESE AMENDMENTS
DUE TO ALLOW THEM TO BE HAVE
FAILED THE RESOURCES THIS BILL
PROVIDES. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
MOVE TO A LADY MEMBERS ON THE
TABLE MEMBERS. SENATOR
HERTZBERG MOVES TO LAY THE
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE AND
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR
WILK ASPIRIN OVER. THE CENTER
NIELSEN ASPIRIN ABOUT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
NO BACKER ARE YOU FOR JUST.
BRADFORD FIVE CABALLERO BYE I
CORTES E. I. DALLY NO DODD. I
TORONTO HI EGGMAN I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG HI
WESO. HI FURTADO I JONES. NO
KAMLAGER I LAYERED I LEYVA. I
LIMON HI MCGUIRE FIVE MELENDEZ
NO MAN. I NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN.
NO A CHIRLA BOTH NO PAN. I
PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO. HI
SKINNER I STERN HI I'M BURKE I
WHITE HOUSE SKI. I WIENER AYE
WILK NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. FOR JUST NOW ROVE.
FIVE THIRTY ONE KNOWS EIGHT THE
MOTION THAT AMENDMENTS ARE LAID
ON THE TABLE. MEMBERS BACK TO
THE BILL IN CHIEF SENATOR
SKINNER. I THINK THERE ARE
OTHER MEMBERS TO HEAD THEREOF
MIKE SEVEN. THIS CENTER ON WELL
MEMBERS- DESERVE WHAT I'VE I'VE
JUST BEEN MADE AWARE OF THIS
ISSUE THAT SENATOR NIELSEN
BROUGHT UP WITH REGARDS TO THE
SCHOOL- SCHOOLS FOR THE BLIND
I'M JUST HOPE AT SOME POINT AS
WITH THIS BILL AND- AS THIS BUT
IS THIS BUDGET TRAILER PROCESS
MOVES FORWARD THAT THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED MIGHT BE
ADDRESSED- IT APPEARS THAT HE
JUST BECAME AWARE OF THIS ISSUE
AND- WAS TRYING TO RECTIFY. I
UNDERSTAND IT WE'VE GOT A
PROCESS AND- WE WANT RESPECT
THAT PROCESS BUT I HOPE THIS
CAN BE LOOKED INTO. SENATOR
LAYERED. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I THOUGHT IT WAS
IMPORTANT THIS TO HIGHLIGHT
WHAT'S IN THIS TRAILER BILL IT
IS THE RESULT OF FIVE MONTHS OF
INTENSE WORK AND I WANT TO
THANK THE SENATORS FROM YOU HI
POWER AND IRVINE AND THE STAFF
FOR ALL THE WORK THAT WAS DONE.
THIS HAS TO BE THE BEST BUDGET
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION IN MODERN
TIMES AND THE BACKDROP IS
WHAT'S NOT IN THE TRAILER BILL
IT IS WHAT WE DID IN THE MAIN
BUDGET BILL WE ALREADY APPROVED
BECAUSE IN JANUARY THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DIDN'T EVEN
RESTORE HIGHER EDUCATION TO
WHERE IT WAS BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC THE STIMULUS- THAT
HAPPENED A FEW WEEKS LATER
RESTORED THE BUDGET TO WORK WAS
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND THE
BUDGET WE APPROVED AND SENT TO
THE GOVERNOR DOES A 5% COST OF
LIVING INCREASE TO THE PRE
PANDEMIC LEVELS. THAT IS REALLY
SIGNIFICANT AND THEN IT ALLOWS
US TO DO EVERYTHING THAT IS IN
THIS TRAILER BILL THERE THIRTY
NINE ITEMS BUT THERE ARE A FEW
THAT ARE REALLY SIGNIFICANT
FIRST IT PAYS OFF THE DEFERRALS
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES SERVE
THE DEFERRALS ARE DONE FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION OUT OF THIS AS
WAS MENTIONED BY THE CHAIR. IT
REVOLUTIONIZES STUDENT NAY WITH
BOTH CAL GRANT AND THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP AND IT IS
REALLY ABOUT OVER THE SHORT
TERM ADDING ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS TO FINANCIAL
AID FOR HIGHER EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA AND POTENTIALLY OVER
TIME MORE THAT IS REALLY
SIGNIFICANT JUST AS WITH THE
pCHILD CARE BILL TRAILER BILL WE
JUST ADOPTED THIS WILL MAKE A
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE IN THE
LIVES OF FAMILIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA IT IS REALLY ABOUT
MOVING TO A DEBT FREE CALL
COLLEGE X. IT'S- NOT. A FREE
COLLEGE EXPERIENCE A DEBT FREE
COLLEGE EXPERIENCE AND AS THE
CHAIR MENTIONED THE PREVIOUS
ROLES WERE REALLY DESIGNED TO
LIMIT PEOPLE ONE FINANCIAL AID
REENTRY STUDENTS WEREN'T
INCLUDED- DEPENDING ON YOUR
GRADES OR OTHER THINGS YOU
WEREN'T INCLUDED. THIS
BASICALLY MEANS THAT IF YOU'RE
SCHOLASTICALLY ELIGIBLE AND
REALLY HAVE A SHOT AT MAKING
SOMETHING OF YOURSELF THE STATE
WILL MAKE A DIFFERENCE FOR YOU
IN THAT PROCESS. ADDITIONALLY
THERE IS A PROPOSAL HERE. OR
THERE IS AN ACTION HERE BASED
ON THE ORIGINAL PROPOSAL TO
RESERVE MORE SPACES AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA FOR IN
STATE STUDENTS AND IT REALLY
TARGETS THE THREE CAMPUSES
WHERE THAT ISSUE IS MOST
PRESENT AND THE GREAT THING IS
WE ARE FUNDING ADDITIONAL
ENROLLMENT IN THIS BUDGET FOR
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SO
IT MAKES IT EVEN EASIER FOR
STATE SPACES FOR IN STATE
STUDENTS. AND WHETHER IT'S OUR
TEACHER TRAINING OR FOR OTHER
THINGS THIS BUDGET MAKES A
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE WE
SHOULD ALL BE PROUD TO VOTE FOR
I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. IN
IRAQ. THANK MATTER PRESENT
COLLEAGUES HODGES TO OF I WANT
TO FIRST SAY I. PRECIADO IN
SUPPORT THIS A GREAT BUDGET AND
FRANKLY THE FOLKS WHO WORKED ON
IT EXTRAORDINARY EFFORT I'VE
YOU KNOW I'VE- SPENT A FEW
YEARS- IN THE SUB TRENCHES OF
WORKING ON BUDGETS AND I KNOW
HOW HARD IT WAS TO DO THAT WOR
AND- IT WAS ESPECIALLY
DIFFICULT THIS YEAR DESPITE THE
FACT. THAT WE HAD A BUNCH OF
MONEY TO WORK WITH OFTEN THAT
MAKES IT MORE DIFFICULT. NOT
EASIER I JUST WANT TO JOIN THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA MONICA WHO IS SOMEWHERE
YEAR. WITH RESPECT TO THE SEVEN.
STATE SCHOOLS YOU KNOW THE
STATE SCHOOLS ARE OFTEN SCHOOLS
THAT- TIME FOR GOD. WELL THERE
ARE MORE OFTEN THAN NOT.
SCHOOLS THAT- GET LOST IN THE-
BUDGET DANCE BECAUSE THEY
FRANKLY HAVE NO CONSTITUENCY
UNLIKE HER. KEY THROUGH TWELVE
OPERATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. SO I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT I HOPE AT SOME POINT IN
TIME AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE REMAINDER OF THIS BUDGET.
WE CAN HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE- CONCERNS ECHOED BY
MY- COLLEAGUE FROM NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHO DO. DID
INTRODUCE THAT- THAT MOTION I
AGREE WITH THE DECISION ON THE
MOTION BUT I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
A CONVERSATION ABOUT THOSE.
ISSUES AT SOME POINT IN TIME
AND I. SUSPECT I SPEAK FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FROM FREMONT AS WELL
THANK YOU. CENTERMAN THANK YOU-
I RISE TO FIRST AND FOREMOST
THANK THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
SANTA CRUZ FOR HIS HARD WORK-
AS PART OF THE BUDGET SUB ONE
COMMITTEE- WE SPENT COUNTLESS
HOURS WORKING ON THIS BILL AND
THIS BUDGET- I ALSO JUST WANT
TO ECHO HIS COMMENTS AND POINT
OUT THAT THIS IS AN INVESTMENT
IN OUR FUTURE ECONOMY- AND SO
MUCH OF WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH
THIS BUDGET THAT I AM PROUD TO
SUPPORT IS ABOUT INVESTING IN
OUR FUTURE I THINK YOU CAN DRAW
A DIRECT LINE FROM OUR CURRENT
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY AND
ROBUSTNESS THE UNIQUELY
RESILIENT NATURE OF OUR
ECONOMY. AND THE PAST
INVESTMENTS WE'VE MADE IN
INSTITUTIONS LIKE THIS YES USE
AND THE UC'S- AND IF WE NEGLECT
THOSE INSTITUTIONS GOING
FORWARD OUR ECONOMY WILL WITHER
IN OUR FUTURE AND SAID I'M
REALLY PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
WHO WORKED ON THIS- AND I URGE
EVERYONE VOTE AYE. THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. CENTER RUBIO THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES OF THE SENATE I ALSO
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
ONE THIRTY TWO I KNOW THAT TOP
COLLEGE IS JUST A DREAM AND SO
MANY OF OUR INNER CITY
COMMUNITIES AND I THINK THIS
BILL JUST REALLY MAKES IT
POSSIBLE FOR THEM TO ACHIEVE
CONSIDERING WE'VE BEEN DEALING
WITH A PANDEMIC EVERY. YOU KNOW
HAVE ACCESS TO CALTRANS THAT
PERHAPS HAVE TO GO BACK TO
COLLEGE TO REINVENT THEMSELVES
AND PERHAPS CHANGE CAREERS
BASED ON WHAT HAPPENED THIS
LAST YEAR BUT I'M ALSO VERY
EXCITED THAT- WE'RE INVESTING
IN THINGS LIKE CRADLE TO CAREER
DATA SYSTEMS TO TRACK THE
PROGRESS OF STUDENTS I ALSO
WORKFORCE TRAINING EMPLOYMENT
HEALTH AND SOCIAL SERVICES
WHICH WILL HELP THEM NAVIGATE
THROUGH THEIR EDUCATIONAL AND
PROFESSIONAL CAREERS ALSO I'M
REALLY JUST ENCOURAGED BY WHAT
WE HAVE HERE AND I WANT TO
THANK THE PRO TIME. ODD
INTERROGATOR SHIP THAT
MINISTRATION AND ALL MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE BUDGET
BOB THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE
INVESTMENT AND I HOPE THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO IN
FUTURE YEARS WITHOUT AYE
ASPIRIN AYE VOTE AS WELL THANK
YOU. SENATOR ALAN. I WANT TO
THANK THEM CENTER WHERE FOR HIS
COMMENTS AND I JUST ALSO WANT
TO JOIN IN IN PRAISE OF THIS
BILL THERE'S SO MUCH GOOD STUFF
IN HERE THINGS THAT MEMBERS
THAT WORK ON FOR SUCH A LONG
TIME THE CRADLE TO CAREER DATA
SYSTEM IT'S GOING TO HELP
BETTER I TRACK THE PROGRESS OF
OUR STUDENTS AND ALSO THE GAPS
IN OUR SYSTEM- PFAFF THAT
SUPPORTS INSTITUTIONAL AID FOR
ALL THE THREE MAJOR HIGHER
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS DO
EMISSIONS PATHWAYS A MAJOR
EXPANSION OF CAL GRANT. THIS
BILL MEMBERS IS GOING TO DO A
LOT TO GET OUR STATE BACK ON
TRACK TOWARD OPENING UP
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
AND ALSO FOLKS ARE COMING BACK
FOR SECOND CHANCES IT AT A
HIGHER EDUCATION- IT'S A IT'S A
THERE THERE'S INCREDIBLY GOOD
STUFF IN HERE AND I'M I'M
EXCITED ABOUT IT- IT'S ALSO
GOING TO HELP GET ARE YOU SEE
BACK ON TRACK I TOWARD THE-
TOWARD EXCELLENCE SO- PLEASE
JOIN ME IN VOTING FOR THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. SENATOR BATES
YEAH. I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND LET ME OUT OF MY
DEEP APPRECIATION TO THE ON MY
COLLEAGUES WHO SERVED ON THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE AND THE BUDGET
CHAIR SO WHEN WE RAISE THESE
ISSUES CONSIDER THAT THOSE OF
US WHO WERE NOT PART OF THAT
PROCESS. OFF SOMEWHAT IN THE
DARK ON THE HIGHER EDUCATION
BILL THE THING THAT CAUGHT MY
EYE THAT TROUBLING AND IT IS
THE FACT THAT CALIFORNIANS ARE
GOING TO BE ALLOWED ONLY TO
STUDENTS WHO ARE GOING TO BE
ENROLLED IN UC SCHOOLS AND I'LL
SHARE WITH YOU A STORY I IN MY
DISTRICT- BEFORE THE PANDEMIC I
WAS VISITED BY THREE STUDENTS
ARE THE PLAN MAY I MENTION THAT
THESE ARE STUDENTS SUB. OF
COLOR ARE WHO WERE ATTENDING
THE UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO
THEY HAD A CAL GRANT IN THE
UNIVERSITY WAS MATCHING THAT
THESE YOUNG LADIES COULD.
ATTEND THAT SCHOOL. NOT
ALLOWING. THAT CALGARY THESE
THREE INDIVIDUALS MIGHT NOT
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO HAVE A
COLLEGE EDUCATION. BECAUSE THE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM WITHIN HALF
OF THAT THE TIME GIVEN THEIR
AGE AND WHEN THEY WERE SEEKING
ADMISSION. SO I'D LIKE US TO
CONSIDER. I KNOW THAT'S NOT.
POTENTIAL TODAY. BUT I THINK
THAT WE NEED TO REVISIT THE CAL
GRANT SCHOOLS HAVE PROVIDED
WHAT I CONSIDER TO BE. A VERY
FUNDAMENTAL BASE OFFER
STUDENTS. YOU KNOW ACROSS THE
BOARD. AND WHEN OUR
UNIVERSITIES ARE IMPACTED AND
THAT IS A YEAR IN WHICH YOU'RE
GOING TO TRANSFER FROM A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. MAYBE THE
ONLY SCHOOL THAT THE OPEN WOULD
BE A UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO
WHICH HAS A ROBUST OUR
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM. BECAUSE
THEY HAVE A WONDERFUL
FOUNDATION. FROM PEOPLE WHO
WENT THERE AND CONTRIBUTED TO
THAT SO. THAT NEEDS TO BE
CONSIDERED. AS WE GO FORWARD
AND TODAY I CAN GO LAY OFF THIS
JUST TO MAKE MY POINT. BUT
AGAIN I THANK YOU FOR THE HARD
WORK IF IT'S DIFFICULT TO HIT
EVERY SINGLE ISSUE. BUT THIS
ONE CAUGHT MY EYE BECAUSE- IT
WAS SO INSPIRING I TO BE
SITTING WITH THESE YOUNG WOMEN.
WHO FOR ANY OTHER REASON THAN
NOT HAVING A CAL GRANT WOULD
HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO
TO. A VERY ODD SIGNIFICANT
UNIVERSITY AND IN OUR STATE
THANK YOU. FOR ANY FURTHER. OR
DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF. BEING
NINE SENATOR SKINNER MAY
CONCLUDE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT ONE- JUST WHITE
CORRECTION IN REFERENCE THAT
ARE- COLLEAGUE. I JUST MADE IS
THAT- THE CAL GRANTS ARE
AVAILABLE FOR MORE THAN JUST
THE UC SYSTEM THEY'RE AVAILABLE
FOR CSU UC COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
ON AN ON THE OTHER ISSUE THAT
WAS RAISED IF LANGUAGE IN THIS
TRAILER BILL INADVERTENTLY.
EXCLUDES ANY STATE. INSTITUTE
OF HIGHER EDUCATION WE CAN
ADJUST THAT IN AUGUST NOW ONE
ONE DISADVANTAGE OF THE SEVENTY
TWO HOUR RULE IS THAT IF AND IF
THERE WAS AN INADVERTENT
EXCLUSION. THEN WE COULD PRIOR
TO THE SEVENTY TWO HOUR RULE
HAVE AMENDED IT SAY ON THE
FLOOR. BUT WITH THE SEVENTY TWO
HOUR RULE WE CANNOT AMEND ON
THE FLOOR AND IF WE WERE TO
DELAY THE ACTION ON THIS
TRAILER BILL THEN THE OTHER
PROVISIONS WOULD NOT GO INTO
EFFECT SO. THE THESE
ADJUSTMENTS IN CALGARY AND TO
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP ALL OF
THAT ARE EFFECTIVE RIGHT AWAY
IN SO SOME STUDENTS WHO OF
COURSE WILL START SCHOOL SOON
MAY HAVE THEIR FINANCIAL AID
PACKAGE- IN FACT MODIFIED. BUT
THEY WOULD NOT IF WE DID NOT
ACT UNTIL AUGUST NOW THE BILL
HAS BEEN INFERENCE SB VERSION
OF THIS BILL HAS BEEN IN PRINT
FOR WEEKS. THE AB VERSION HAS
BEEN IN PRINT FOR LESS THAN
WEEKS BUT A NUMBER OF THE MORE
THAN A NUMBER OF DAYS. AND SO
THE BENEFIT OF IT IN PRINT IS
IF SUCH THINGS ARE COSTS AND WE
CAN BE ALERTED IN THE TIMELY
MANNER THAN WE CAN IMAGINE. SO
STAFF WILL OBVIOUSLY LOOK AT
THAT WHAT IS NOT APPROPRIATE TO
AMEND TO DAY BECAUSE THEN WE
COULD NOT ACT SO. I WOULD NOT
DELAY THE OTHER GREAT
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL AS HAVE
BEEN DESCRIBED BY MANY FOLKS ON
THE FLOOR AND I ASK YOU FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
FIVE ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES. BAKER HI PORGES.
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
CORTESE AYE DALLY NO DODD. I
THERE ARE SO I EGGMAN I GLAZER.
I GONZALEZ I GROWTH HERTZBERG I
WESO. HI FOR TODD I JONES.
KAMLAGER I LAYERED I LEYVA I
LIMóN AYE MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ
NO MAN I NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN. A
CHIRLA BOTH. I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
AMBERG HI WHITE HOUSE SKI FIVE
WIENER AYE WILK. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS WELCOME NOW.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
HEBASED. NO GORGEOUS. GROW
JONES. NIELSEN. FIVE THIRTY TWO
NOTES FOR THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
FORTY SEVEN. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLYBILL ONE
THIRTY FIVE BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN ACT
RELATING TO HUMAN SERVICES
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. SENATOR SKINNER THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS HUMAN
SERVICES TRAILER BILL AB ONE
THIRTY FIVE- MAKES AN INCREASE
TO OUR GRANTS FOR CAL WORKS
RECIPIENTS AND- AS YOU KNOW
THOSE ARE SOME OF OUR LOWEST
INCOME CALIFORNIANS PRIMARILY
MOTHERS WITH CHILDREN. IT ALSO
AUTHORIZES A ONE TIME FLAT RATE
PAYMENT FROM THE PANDEMIC
EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE FINE TO
EACH CAL WORKS ASSISTANCE UNIT.
AND VERY IMPORTANTLY I THINK IN
WHEN I WAS START TALKING. IN
THE CHILD CARE ITEM ABOUT THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO HAVE STILL NOT
RETURNED TO WORK BECAUSE THEY
ARE TAKING CARE OF FAMILY
MEMBERS THAT OTHERWISE BEFORE
WERE BEING TAKEN CARE OF BY
SOMEONE ELSE. THIS BILL
PERMANENTLY REPEALS THE 7%
REDUCTION IN SERVICE HOURS FOR
THE IN HOME. SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES PROGRAM AND OF COURSE
BY ECSTATIC EXPANSION AND WE
HAVE. FOLKS THAT NEED CARE. WE
CAN ENSURE THAT THEY ARE TAKING
CARE OF- IT ALSO PROVIDES FOR
AN AGE BASED TARGETED EXPANSION
TO ELIGIBILITY FOR OUR
CALIFORNIA FOOD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. AND IT ESTABLISHES THE
IN ARREARS PAYMENT PROGRAM FOR
FOLKS THAT ARE BEHIND ON THEIR
UTILITY BILLS AND WITH THAT I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. CENTER SKINNER YOU
MAKE INCLUDES. HELLO THANK YOU
I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES NO BACKER FIVE FOR
JUST NO BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO
AYE CORTESE'S HI SALLY NO DODD.
I THERE ALSO I EGGMAN AYE
GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO ARE YOU
FURTADO I JONES NO KAMLAGER I
LAYERED. I LEYVA AYE LIMóN AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ NO MAN I
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF
BOTH. PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER I
STERN AYE I'M BURKE I WHITE
HOUSE SKI FIVE WIENER AYE WILK.
NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS GROVE. OCHO A BUG. FIVE
THIRTY ONE NO SEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY
EIGHT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY
BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AN ACT RELATING TO
HOUSING AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION AIRPORT TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BERLET BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. CENTER
SKINNER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS BILL IS
OUR TRAILER BILL ON
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING. AND I
THINK NONE OF US NEED TO BE
REMINDED OF THE- CRISIS THAT
THE STATE IS IN IN REGARDS TO
BOTH. HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING.
CAN WE WITH OUR BUDGET THAT WE
ADOPTED AND THIS TRAILER BILL
WE ARE. TAKING HISTORIC FOR
MAKING HISTORIC INVESTMENTS. IN
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS AND
THE HOMELESS THIS AREA. WE ARE
PUTTING TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS.
TOWARDS REDUCING THAT PROBLEM.
LOOTING INCREASING OUR- PROJECT
HOME KEY WHICH WILL ALLOW US TO
PURCHASE TO ACQUIRE PROPERTIES
THAT CAN BE CONVERTED TO
PERMANENT HOUSING AND VERY
IMPORTANTLY ONE BILLION EACH
YEAR FOR THE NEXT FOR THIS YEAR
AND NEXT Q. ARE LARGE CITIES
WHERE THE MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS ON HOUSE FOLKS
LIVE- THE OTHER THING IS THAT
THIS BILL DOES. IS SET US ON
THE PATH TO HAVE A THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT WHICH WILL
ALLOW US TO SUPPORT. FIRST TIME
HOMEBUYERS LOW INCOME FIRST
TIME HOMEBUYERS. BEYOND A SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR GRANT
PROGRAM TO HELP REGION'S AND
LOCALS ACHIEVE THEIR HOUSING
GOALS WHILE REDUCING CLIMATE
IMPACTS SO THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT TRAILER BILL TO ALLOW
US. TO FULLY EXPAND THE FUNDS
THAT WE AUTHORIZED IN THE
BUDGET ON THESE VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUES OF HOMELESSNESS AND
HOUSING WITHOUT I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SENATE
ARCHULETA BACKGROUND RESIDENT I
WOULD LIKE TO- PRAISES FIGURED
THAT PARTICULAR BILL AB ONE
FORTY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS WERE TALKING ABOUT
ENTRY LEVEL WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE BUT CHOIR IN THE DREAMS
WE ARE GIVING OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS A CHANCE TO
PARTICIPATE WITH ALL THEIR
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE IN DIRE
NEED OF CORRECTING THIS
HOMELESS AND SO I THINK THIS IS
OUR OPPORTUNITY AT THE STATE
SENATE OUR OPPORTUNITY AS THIS
STATE TO REACH OUT TO THOSE WHO
REALLY NEED HELP AND SHOW THAT
WE DO HAVE COMPASSION AND WE DO
HAVE. THE ABILITY CARE AND TAKE
CARE OF SO MANY THAT NEED OUR
HELP SO I URGE AN AYE VOTE ON
AB ONE FORTY. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THING MAN
CENTER SKINNER- THANK YOU I ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE AND SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
I BAKER FIVE FORGES AYE
BRADFORD. FIVE CABALLERO I
CORTES HE- VALLEY. DODD ARE YOU
THERE ALSO I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW HERTZBERG
HI HUESO. FIVE HER TADO I JONES
I KAMLAGER I WHERE'D I LEYVA I
LIMóN FIVE MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ
AYE MIN AYE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN.
I A SHOW OF BOTH I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER AYE STERN I- BURKE I
WHITE HOUSE SKIING. FIVE WIENER.
FIVE WILK HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS CORTELLI. BALLY
GROVE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS CORTESE I. DALLY GROVE.
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ONTO FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY UP MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE FORTY EIGHT BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
RESOURCES AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS THIS IS THE RESOURCES
TRAILER BILL. AND IT-
ESTABLISHES. THE WATER AND- I
NEVER CAN SAY THE WORD IT'S FOR
TO BEEN IN A RE ALLTHEIR- IN
REAL. TO WATER AND AT THE STATE
WATER CONTROL WOULD SET UP THE
SPINE WOULD ALLOW US TO HELP
RESIDENTS PAY THOSE BILLS IT
ALSO AUTHORIZES. STATE AGENCIES
TO MAKE GRANTS AND DIRECT
EXPENDITURES TO PROVIDE INTERIM
OR MEDIA DROUGHT RELIEF. TO
ADDRESS IMPACTS ON HUMAN SAFETY
DANCE FISH AND WILDLIFE
RESOURCES AND WE KNOW THAT. OUR
DROUGHT IS ALSO IN CRISIS
PROPORTIONS AND CURRENTLY. AND
A TRANSFER CERTAIN POWERS
DUTIES AND RESPONSIBILITIES OF
THE WILDFIRE SAFETY DIVISION
FROM THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION TO THE NEWLY
ESTABLISHED OFFICE OF ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY IN THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY- AND IT INCREASES OUR
OIL SPILL PREVENTION AND
ADMINISTRATION FEE FROM. SIXTY
FIVE POINT ZERO SIX FIVE TWO
POINT ZERO EIGHT FIVE PER
BARREL OF CRUDE OR PETROLEUM
PRODUCTS AND IMPOSES TO BE ALSO
ON RENEWABLE FUEL. AND YES- TWO
SENSES A ONE CENT- ANYWAY
WITHOUT AYE ELSEVIER AYE VOTE.
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS I JUST WANT TO
RISE AND SAY LAST WEEK WE
PASSED LEGISLATION TO PUT FIVE
HUNDRED. MILLION DOLLARS BACK
IN THE BUDGET FOR. FIRE AND I
DON'T SAY THIS TRAILER BILL I
THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO BE IN
THERE IS NOT IN THERE. THIS
WE'RE GONNA LOSE TWO MONTHS
WORTH OF BEING ABLE TO FIND
PROJECTS THAT ARE SHOVEL READY
SEQUEL READY ON THE GROUND
THERE ARE CD'S AND FIRE SAFE
COUNCIL SO I JUST WANT TO BE ON
THE RECORD THAT. I'M NOT GOING
AWAY I'M GONNA CONTINUE TO BEAT
UP ON THIS UNTIL WE GET OUR
FIRE SAFE COUNCILS FUNDED I
KNOW THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
HAS HEARD THIS MANY TIMES BUT I
JUST WANT EVERYBODY TO KNOW.
I'M WATCHING AND WE NEED TO GET
THESE RESOURCES ON THE GROUND
SOONER THAN LATER THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND THANK YOU FOR
PUTTING UP WITH ME. SENATOR
NELSON. BARBARA THE LADY IN
THE- OF THE SENATE ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS HERE IS THAT THE
MONIES FOR FILE FOR AN WILD
LAND CLEAN UP AND PROTECTION
WHICH IS THE BEST WAY TO SOLVE
OUR PROBLEMS WITH THE FIRES
BECAUSE WE'VE ALLOWED FOR
DECADES THE FUEL. TO ACCUMULATE.
HOWEVER A GOOD PORTION OF THE
MONEY IN THE BUDGET. IS SUBJECT
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DETERMINING IF QUOTE NEEDED.
I'M NOT WILLING TO GIVE THEM
THAT AUTHORITY. TOO OFTEN THIS
LEGISLATURE FEEDS TO THE LEAD
TO THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH OUR
FLOORING WE SHOULD BE THE ONE
TO SAY WHERE THAT MONEY IS.
SPENT IN A DISCLOSURE BY A
PUBLIC- RADIO SYSTEM THEY DID A
STUDY OF MONIES THAT WE HAD
APPROPRIATED OVER A YEAR AGO
FOR FORCING WILDLAND CLEANUP.
IT DID NOT GET SPENT. AND WE'VE
GOT FIRES RAGING ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA NOW NOW WOULD THAT
HAVE THE EXPENDITURE OF THAT
MONEY HEALTH. PROBABLY AT LEAST
IN SOME AREAS I GUARANTEE YOU
IT WOULD HAVE THE FUNDAMENTAL
POINT WE OUGHT NOT TO CEDE. OUR
AUTHORITY AS LEGISLATORS
REPRESENTING THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA TO THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH TO MAKE DETERMINATIONS
ABOUT THE EXPENDITURE OF MONEY
WE HAVE APPROVED IN THE BUDGET.
HURTADO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AT TODAY I RISE IN
RELUCTANT OPPOSITION TO SB ONE
FOUR EIGHT- THIS BILL PROVIDES
ME THE FLEXIBILITY TO ENSURE
DROPPED BUT IT MAKES IT INTO
THE HANDS THAT NEED IT THE
MOST. AND THIS YEAR I HAVE
WORKED HARD TO ENSURE THAT WE
MAKE NEEDED INVESTMENTS IN OUR
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE TO BETTER
PREPARES FOR FUTURE DROUGHT
YEARS. UNFORTUNATELY I CANNOT
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY IT ALSO
INCLUDES AN INCREASE THE
INCREASE IN THE FEE CAP CHARGE
PER BARREL OF OIL AND PETROLEUM
PRODUCTS EXPENSE COLLECTION OF
THE FEE TO RENEWABLE FUELS AND
LINKS THE FEE TO THE CONSUMER
PRICE INDEX. AS PEOPLE IN OUR
STATE ARE STILL RECOVERING
PHYSICALLY AND FINANCIALLY FROM
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC AS
WE ARE ENTERING WHAT IS LIKELY
TO BE DEVASTATING DROUGHT. THAT
WILL IMPACT ARE CONSTRUCTED
CONSTITUENTS ACCESS TO WATER.
AN INCREASE THE PRICE OF THE
FOOD I CANNOT IN GOOD
CONSCIENCE VOTE FOR A MEASURE
THAT HAS THE POTENTIAL TO ADD
TO THE BURDEN. THANK YOU.
FEDERATE HOUSEKI. THE COMMANDER
OF PRESIDENT SO TO REFRESH
EVERYONE'S MEMORY. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN JANUARY
PROVIDED TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS FOR
EARLY ACTION WILDFIRE
PREVENTION. IN THIS BODY AND
THE WORK WITH MY COLLEAGUES ON
SEPT TWO. AUGMENTED THAT BY TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
ALMOST TWICE AS MUCH AS WITH
THE GOVERNOR WAS TALKING ABOUT.
FOR WILDFIRE PREVENTION THAT
MONEY. IS WHAT THE GOOD WORK IN
THE BUDGET CHAIR AND THE STAFF.
IS OUT THE DOOR. THE SIERRA
NEVADA CONSERVANCY GOT SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS MORE THAN
THEY'VE EVER HAD AND YES THAT
MONEY HAS BEEN TIED UP. WE TOOK
A ACTION IN THIS BODY
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE BOOK
WITH THE BUDGET. THAT WE WOULD
BE SPENDING AN EXTRA BILLION
DOLLARS OVER FIVE YEARS THAT
NUMBER NOW STANDS WITH THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION HAT WE TALK
ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX.
THAT NEEDS TO BE PROGRAMMED OUT
AND WE'VE HEARD PEOPLE LOUD AND
CLEAR THAT SOME OF OUR STATE
AGENCIES ARE NOT PUSHING THE
MONEY OUT IN GETTING THE WORK
TO OUR PARTNERS AT THE FIRE
COUNCILS. AT THE CONSERVANCY'S
AT THE REGIONAL PARKS AT THE
STATE PARK SO. MY COMMITMENT IS
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THAT. MANY OF THE PACKAGES
THE CLIMATE PACKAGE BEFORE THE
YEARLY FIRE. PREVENTION PACKAGE.
THE CAP AND TRADE PACKAGE ARE
UNFORTUNATELY DID NOT MAKE IT
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE TODAY
BONTA ON JULY FIFTEENTH WE WILL
CONTINUE WE CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THOSE WE DO HAVE PIECES HERE
FONG AS WE CAN AS WELL AS THE
DROUGHT PACKAGE THERE ARE SOME
PIECES HERE TO DROP PACKAGE BUT
THERE ARE PIECES THAT REMAIN
THAT WE HAVEN'T. WE HAVEN'T
WORKED ON IT'S NOT EVERYTHING
THAT EVERYBODY ANTICIPATED AND
RESOURCES EVERYTHING STILL IN
PLAY. AS FAR AS THE SENATE'S
SINCE PRIORITIES- BUT MANY MUCH
OF THE WORK THAT GOT OUT EARLY
HAS BEEN DONE UNFORTUNATELY
IT'S NOT AS MUCH AS WE WANTED
TO BUT LOT OF THE FIRE
PREVENTION OF FUNDS THAT GOT
OUT. WELL WERE PUT TO WORKING
WITH THAT- I URGE. PATIENCE ON
THESE BIG. FUNDING PROGRAMS
BUT- TONIGHT BOTH. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SINGMAN
CENTER SKINNER YOU MAY CONCLUDE
THANK YOU ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES NO BACKER. HI
FORGES NO BRADFORD HI CABALLERO
I CORTES E. I DALLY NO DODD.
FIVE THERE ALSO I EGGMAN AYE
GLAZER. FIVE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. ARE YOU
FURTADO NO JONES NO KAMLAGER. I
LAYERED I LEYVA HI LIMóN FIVE
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A CHOI
BOGUE NO PAN. I PORTANTINO FIVE
ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE AMBERG. WHITE HOUSE
HE- I WIENER I WILK NO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE
AMBERG. PRICE TWENTY NINE KNOWS
NINE THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER FORTY SIX. SENATOR
SKINNER MADAM SECRETARY FORTY
EIGHT- ONE THIRTY THREE OKAY I
GOT IT. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
pCOMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH AND MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR SKINNER
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THIS IS OUR
HEALTH BARNABAS TRAILER BILL
AND IT ALSO HAS MANY. EXCELLENT
ELEMENTS THAT WILL ENABLE OUR
BUDGET ACTION TO PROVIDE.
REALLY IMPROVED SERVICES TO
CALIFORNIANS IT IMPLEMENTS THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE TO ENSURE AN
INNOVATIVE AND PREVENTION BASED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH TWENTY FIVE
AND YOUNGER. IT ALSO ADDS NEW
HEALTH EQUITY AND QUALITY
REQUIREMENTS FOR HEALTH CARE
SERVICE PLANS UNDER THE KNOX
KEEN ACT. IT IMPLEMENTS OUR
MEDIC CAL CAL AYMAN ISSUE TO
WHICH WILL TRANSFORM THE MEDI
CAL SYSTEM. TO RE ORIENT IT
TOWARDS A WHOLE PERSON CARE
APPROACH THAT TARGETS THE
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
IT REDUCES HEALTH DISPARITIES
AND INEQUITIES. IT EXPANDSFULL
SCOPE MEDI CAL COVERAGE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE INCOME
ELIGIBLE AGE FIFTY AND OVER.
BEGINNING ON MAY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND IT PHASES OUT
THE ASSETS TEST TO DETERMINE
ELIGIBILITY FOR MEDI CAL FOR
SENIORS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES. I'M AN
EXPERIENCED POSTPARTUM MEDICARE
ELIGIBILITY FROM SIXTY DAYS
UNTIL TWELVE MONTHS AFTER THE
END OF AN INDIVIDUAL'S
PREGNANCY. AND ESTABLISHES THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUUM
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM WHICH
WILL AWARD GRANTS OR OTHERWISE
BUILD OUT THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
PROVIDE A FULL CONTINUUM OF
BEHAVIOR HEALTH. FACILITIES OR
RESOURCES FOR MOBILE CRISIS
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ACUTE
INPATIENT BEDS AND THEN IT.
UPDATES OR MENTAL HEALTH
STUDENT SERVICES ACT TO SUPPORT
THE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR AUGMENTATION
THAT WE GAVE IN THE BUDGET ACT
FOR SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH
PARTNERSHIPS WHICH WE KNOW. NOT
JUST THE SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH
POLAR PARTNERSHIPS BUT ALL OF
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. ITEMS
THAT I'VE MENTIONED RIGHT NOW
IT WE'VE KNOWN THAT WE THAT
THOSE WHO ARE SUFFERING FROM
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. THEY HAVE
A DIFFICULT TIME. ACCESSING
SERVICES AND WE'VE SEEN IT THAT
MUCH MORE DISSED IN HANDS
DURING THIS PANDEMIC YEAR WHERE
MANY MANY OF US WERE CHALLENGED
IT WAS THE TYPE OF CIRCUMSTANCE
THAT WOULD CHALLENGE ALMOST
ANYONE'S MENTAL HEALTH BUT WITH
THAT SCENE IT'S SO APPARENT
THAT WE NEEDED TO FIX NOT ONLY
EXPAND THE SERVICES BUT REVISED
THEM SO THAT THEY- ARE MORE
ACCESSIBLE THROUGH PLACE WHERE
PEOPLE ARE FOR EXAMPLE IT
SCHOOLS AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL DOES. AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB ONE
THIRTY THREE. CENTER EGGMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM
SPEAKER I JUST ALSO WANT TO
STAND AND BRYSON IN STRONG
SUPPORTOF THIS BILL THIS IS
AND WE'VE ALSO A THOUSAND TIMES
WITH THANKS THANKS TO THE-BUDGET STAFF AND EVERYBODY WHO
WORKED. SO HARD ON THIS AND AS
WELL AS ALL OF THE ADVOCATE TO
REALLY LET US KNOW LOUD AND
CLEAR THROUGH HOURS AND HOURS
OF HEARINGS- WHAT THE NEEDS ARE
OF THE COMMUNITY- SO IT IT IS
JUST AND JUST WANT TO SAY LIKE
AS A SOCIAL WORKER TO BE ABLE
TO GET RID OF THE ASSET TEST SO
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE TO SPEND
THEIR LAST DOLLAR SPENDING
DOWN. TO THEY CAN QUALIFY FOR
HEALTH CARE IS JUST INCREDIBLE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO DO- TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE MORE HEALTH
CARE FOR PEOPLE REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS IS
INCREDIBLE THAT WERE ABLE TO
DO. AND YOU'VE HEARD ME TALK A
LOT ABOUT THE NEED FOR A
CONTINUUM OF CARE WHAT WE
ACTUALLY HAVE BED SPACE AND
FACILITIES FOR PEOPLE TO BE-
BUT I KNOW IT'S NOT AS EXCITING
TO TALK ABOUT ACTUAL BED SPACE
FOR PEOPLE BUT IF WE DON'T
PROVIDE. THAT AND WHERE PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO BE HOUSED IN STATE
AND GET TREATMENT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO SEE THE CRISIS THAT
WE SEE ON OUR STREETS THAT'S
GOT TO BE THE ENTIRE CONTINUUM
SO HAVING MONEY TO ACTUALLY
BUILD OUT THE INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR MENTAL HEALTH POPULATION IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. AS WELL
AS BE ABLE TO ESTABLISH OUR
MOBILE CRISIS TEAMS WE'VE ALL
BEEN TALKING A LOT ABOUT YOU
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO HAVE A POLICE
OFFICER SHOW UP AT A LOT OF
PLACES WHERE IT SHOULD BE.
SOMEBODY WHO IS MORE PREPARED
TO BE ABLE TO DEAL WITH A
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS THIS MONEY
THIS TO CONTINUE OF CARE
EXPANSION WILL BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THAT FOR SO MANY OF
THOSE THINGS. MENTAL HEALTH IN
SCHOOLS WEKEEP TALKING ABOUT
THAT SO INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT I
WOULD LIKE TO KNOWLEDGE.
SENATOR FROM SAN JOSE ON HIS
WORK ON BEING ABLE TO MAKE SURE
WE GET THAT YOU BE I I THERE
FOR FOSTER KIDS AND REALLY SOME
OF THE INNOVATIVE THINGS THEY
DIDN'T SANTA CLARA COUNTY THAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO NOW
REPLICATE THAT. ACROSS THE
STATE IS JUST INCREDIBLE WORK
AND SO I AM VERY PROUD TO BE
ABLE TO VOTE FOR THIS BUDGET BY
ANNA AND I ENCOURAGE AN AYE
VOTE FOR ALL OF US. TO CARE
ABOUT THE HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH OF OUR- VULNERABLE CAL.
SENATOR EYES OF. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I OUT RISE ALSO I'M
SO PROUD AND SO EXCITED ABOUT
EVERYTHING THAT'S IN THIS- IN
THIS BILL WITH REGARDS TO
HEALTH CARE I SPECIALLY WANT TO
THANK OF THE SENATOR FROM
STOCKTON FROM SACRAMENTO ON
FIRMER WITH SIDE AND OUR
LEADERSHIP UP FOR STANDING UP.
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WILL WORK
SO HARD AND CONTRIBUTED TO THE
STATE I YEAR FIND THEMELVES
UNABLE TO ACCESS HEALTH CARE-
THIS LAST WEEK I WAS OF TALKING
TO AN OLDER. WOMAN FROM
RIVERSIDE WHO JUST- QUIETLY
SOBBED AND SOBBED ABOUT HOW SHE
WAS NOW GOING TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE. SHE
TALKED ABOUT HOW SHE HAD WORKED
IN THE FIELDS FOR DECADES AND
ALL THE ILLNESSES THAT CAME
FROM THAT HARD WORK AND YET SHE
WAS NEVER ABLE TO ACCESS HEALTH
CARE IN A WAY THAT PREVENTED
IT- FURTHER- DETERIORATION IN
HER HEALTH- AND I. THINK OF HER
AS WE TAKE THIS VOTE HOW THERE
WILL BE SEVERAL HUNDRED
THOUSAND MORE ON MEN AND WOMEN
WHO HAVE WORKED SO HARD. AND
NOW WILL HAVE HEALTH CARE.
FIELD I THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
AND I AS FOR MY BOOK. SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I REALLY WANNA
PERSONAL ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUES FROM LOS ANGELES
WHO I KNOW HAS BEEN FIGHTING
FOR- FOR THESE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS FOR SO MANY YEARS-TO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE PEOPLE WHO
ARE PART OF OUR COMMUNITY ARE
ABLE TO BE TREATED LIKE. FULL
HUMAN BEINGS BECAUSE THEY ARE
IN IN THIS COUNTRY- AND THIS IS
THE- HAS A HUGE STEP FORWARD- I
ALSO JUST WANNA. ON TO SAY THAT
THE PHASING OUT OF THE ASSET
TEST. I THINK IT'S HARD TO
OVERSTATE THE IMPACT IT'LL HAVE
IN VARIOUS MEMBERS OF THIS
CHAMBER HAVE WORKED OVERTIME.
IN VARIOUS- AREAS TO TRY TO GET
RID OF THIS INCREDIBLY. AFARIA
SEN DESTRUCTIVE ASSET TEST.
WHICH GIVES A HUGE INCENTIVE.
FOR LOW INCOME PEOPLE ON PUBLIC
BENEFITS NOT TO SAVE MONEY. NOT
TO EVEN HAVE A CAR THAT'S YOU
KNOW GOD FORBID IS NOT FALLING
APART BECAUSE OF GOD FOR BID
YOU SAVE SOME MONEY FOR YOUR
KIDS EDUCATION OR FOR HEALTH
CARE NEEDS OF A YOU KNOW GOING
TO BANKRUPTCY IF YOU GET SICK.
YOU'RE GONNA GET KICKED OFF A
PUBLIC BENEFITS ITS EXACT
OPPOSITE OF WHAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING WE NEED TO EMPOWER PEOPLE
TO BE STABLE THEIR LIVES. AND
INTO LIFT THEMSELVES WITH HELP
OUT OF POVERTY IN THE ASSET
TEST KEEPS PEOPLE IN POVERTY SO
I'M JUST THRILLED THAT WE'RE
TAKING A DECISIVE STEP FORWARD
TO GET RID OF THAT TERRIBLE
TEST THANK YOU. SENATOR PENN
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS I TO ARISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF- THIS- BUDGET
TRAILER BILL I THINK MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE READY MADE NOTE
OF MANY OF THE OUTSTANDING
FEATURES OF THIS BILL AND WE
HEAR THE SENATE HAVE- WORKED
HARD TO BUILD ON- THE FEDERAL
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT TO EXPAND
ON IT TO EXPAND COVERAGE- YEAH
I'VE OFTEN SAID. COVERAGE IS
CERTAINLY ESSENTIAL AND VERY
IMPORTANT BUT IT'S NOT ENOUGH
IN ITSELF SO IT ALSO MAKE NOTE
IN ADDITION TO THE EXPANSION
COVERAGES- THE COVERAGE
EXPANSIONS WE SEE IN THIS
TRAILER BILL WE ARE ALSO BOLDLY
LOOKING AT HOW DO WE ACTUALLY
IMPROVE OUR MEDICAL PROGRAM.
HOW DO WE IMPROVE ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH FOR CHILDREN FOR
OTHER POPULATIONS HOW DO WE
IMPROVE OUR CARE FOR THE
ELDERLY NOW I WILL SAY THAT-
SAMPLE TO CALAIS MA'AM- THE
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH- WE
ARE MAKING AN IMPORTANT
INVESTMENT BUT THEY'RE STILL
ONGOING WORK WE ARE GOING HAVE
TO DO. HERE IN THE SENATE AND
AS LEGISLATURE TO BE SURE THAT
THOSE PROGRAMS THIS- THEY'VE
BEEN PROPOSED. ARE GONNA BE
EXECUTED NO WAY- THAT IS
EFFECTIVE- THAT THAT WE
PROVIDE. OVERSIGHT BUT THIS IS
THE FIRST STEP BECAUSE OF
WITHOUT RESOURCES WE CANNOT
BEGIN THIS WORK. SO I MAKE NOTE
OF BOTH OUR INVESTMENT IN
IMPROVING PASS PROGRAMS
EXPANDING COVERAGE BUT ALSO THE
FACT THAT WE ARE ALSO TAKING
STEPS. TO NOT ONLY PROVIDE THE
COVERAGE BACKSEAT IMPROVE THE
VERY COVERAGE PROGRAMS THAT
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO RECEIVE.
AND FOR THAT I CERTAINLY HOPE
THAT- EVERYONE HERE CAN VOTE
FOR THIS TRAILER BILL AND WILL
CONTINUE OUR WORK AND TRYING TO
BE SURE WE IMPROVE CARE FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. FOR ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NINE CENTER SKINNER YOU
MAY CONCLUDE. ASPIRO VOTE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI FIVE ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES NO BACKER. I
FOR JUST NO BRADFORD I
CABALLERO HIGH COURT HEAVY.
FIVE DALLY NO DODD HI THERE
ALSO I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER. HI
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI
WITH SO ARE YOU FURTADO I JONES
NO KAMLAGER I GLARED I LEYVA
AYE LIMóN AYE MCGUIRE. HI
MELENDEZ NO MAN. NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF BOTH NO
HAN. I PORTANTINO I ROCKED I
RUBIO AYE SKINNER. I STERN HI
I'M BURKE I Y. CASKEY I WIENER
AYE WILK NO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE MAN I.
FIVE THIRTY ONE KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY ONE
SENATOR SKINNER MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
FIFTY THREE BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO BUDGET. CENTERS CANADA FOR
YEARS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS AB ONE FIFTY THREE IS
OUR CHILD WELFARE TRAILER BILL.
AND THIS BILL THAT YOU MAY HAVE
SO FAR DETECTED MY ENTHUSIASM
FOR THE BILLS THAT WE ARE
VOTING ON TODAY AND THIS ONE I
AM PARTICULARLY ENTHUSIASTIC
ABOUT. BECAUSE IT WILL END.
CALIFORNIA'S PRACTICE OF
SENDING SOME OF OUR FOR
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE TO OUT
OF STATE PLACEMENTS. I'M SURE
SOME OF YOU HAVE READ WITH
HORROR THE MEDIA ACCOUNTS OF
SOME OF THOSE FACILITIES OUT OF
STATE ANY ABUSE THAT THOSE
CHILDREN SUFFERED. AND ALL OF
THOSE CHILDREN WERE BROUGHT
BACK TO CALIFORNIA THIS YEAR.
BUT WE STILL HAD IN- IN STATUTE
THE ABILITY FOR THEM TO BE
RETURNS TO FACILITIES OUT OF
STATE. AND THIS BILL WILL.
ENSURE THAT AS OF JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND REQUIRE
THAT ALL YOUTH B. IN CALIFORNIA
BY JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. IT ALSO MAKES STATUTORY
CHANGES TO IMPLEMENT THE
FEDERAL FAMILIES FIRST
PREVENTION SERVICES ACT WHICH
INCLUDES EXERCISING OUR OPTION
TO RECEIVE FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
APPROVED PREVENTION SERVICES.
END OF THE SHOW WHICH IS A FIVE
YEAR CHILDREN'S CRISIS
CONTINUING PILOT PROGRAM. AND
THEN AS ANOTHER FIRST FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT PARK
BEGINS. EIGHT GUARANTEED INCOME
PILOT PROGRAM WHICH CITIES OR
COUNTIES COULD APPLY FOR CITIES
OR COUNTIES THAT WANT TO DO
THIS. TO PROVIDE GRANTS TO THAT
WOULD GIVE GUARANTEED INCOME
PAYMENTS TO PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS NOW THE PEOPLE
THAT WOULD BE PRIORITIZE FOR
THAT. ARE YOUTH THAT ARE
TRANSITIONING OUT OF FOSTER
CARE AND PREGNANT INDIVIDUALS
SO FAR THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
HAS JUST LAUNCHED SUCH A
PROGRAM OAKLAND AND STOCKTON
HAVE PILOTED. AND THIS. THIS
TRAILER BILL AND OUR BUDGET
ACTION WOULD MAKE CALIFORNIA
THE FIRST STATE. TO IN EFFECT
ALLOW ANY CITY OR COUNTY TO
APPLY FOR THESE FUNDS AND SET
UP SUCH A PILOT. AND WITH THAT
I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. OR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. CENTER WALK THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. IN THE AT I
RISE ACTUALLY IN IN IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL- MY PARTICULAR
DISTRICT IN L. A. COUNTY- I- I
HAVE SHE'S A PARTIAL PART IN L.
A. COUNTY BUT- ONE OUT OF EVERY
THREE FOSTER YOUTH IN L. A.
COUNTY RESIDES IN MY DISTRICT.
I MYSELF AN ASSEMBLYMAN LACKEY
SPENT A LOT OF TIME. TALKING IN
MENTORING WITH FOSTER YOUTH IN
WHICH I'VE DONE A LOT O
LEGISLATION ON FOSTER YOU IF
YOU LOOK AT THE- THE STATS FOR
FOSTER YOUTH ARE DEVASTATING.
THEIR HALF AS LIKELY TO
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
THEIR CHANCE OF GRADUATING FROM
A C. ISSUE ONLY ABOUT 4% DO
THAT. MAYBE TALK TO CDC ARE
THEY DON'T HAVE HARD FACTS BUT
THEY BELIEVE IT. IS IN MANY AS
20% OF THE PRISON POPULATION.
FOR FORMER FOSTER YOUTH. SO I
BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD BE DOING
ALL WE CAN. TO LET THIS LEFTY
SO YOUNG PEOPLE OUT. I DO
THOUGH- THROUGH THE CHAIR HAVE
A HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR. SHE HAD MENTIONED. IN
TERMS OF THE UNIVERSAL BASIC
INCOME. PILOT PROJECT THIRTY
FIVE GOING TO GET THAT. AND IT
SAYS PRIORITIZE. FOR FOSTER
YOUTH. AND FOR AND FOR PREGNANT
YOUTH I'M WONDERING. THAT SAYS
PRIOR PRIORITIZE ARE THERE ANY
OTHER. INDIVIDUALS AT THAT
WOULD BE- ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
UNIVERSAL. INCOME ENTER SKINNER
WILL YOU ACCEPT THE QUESTION
CERTAINLY. THE THE FULL
REGULATIONS HAVE NOT BEEN
DEVELOPED YET AND CLEARLY THE-
AND ONCE THEY- ARE. THEN THE
CITIES AND COUNTIES THAT APPLY
CAN SPECIFY HOWEVER WE HAVE
MADE IT CLEAR THAT THE PRIORITY
IS FOR EXACTLY THE POPULATIONS
THAT YOU REFERENCED WHICH OUR-
FOSTER YOUTH WHO ARE
TRANSITIONING OUT. AND WHO WHO
AND LEX I KNOW THAT- THE
SENATOR. FROM THE SENATE THE
READING AREA UNDERSTANDS THIS
BUT SOME OF OUR OTHER MEMBERS
MAY NOT THAT WHEN YOU ARE IF
YOU'RE IN THE FOSTER SYSTEM UP
TO A CERTAIN AGE. YOU ARE
PROVIDED FOR AND YET THEN WHEN
YOU TRANSITION OUT. WELL WE
HAVE SOME SUPPORT SERVICES
BASICALLY YOU'RE KIND OF JUST
LEFT OUT ON YOUR OWN. AND MOST
OF US HAVE FAMILY SUPPORT
SYSTEMS OUR FOSTR YOUTH DO
NOT. AND SO IT MAKES SENSE. I
THINK THOSE CITIES THAT HAVE
PILOTED SUCH PROGRAMS CAN
PROVIDE THIS KIND OF MINIMAL
SUPPORT AND WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
A YEAR AND HE BASIC INCOME
PILOT. WE'RE TALKING IN THE
RANGE OF FIVE HUNDRED A MONTH
MAYBE ONE THOUSAND AT THE MAX.
THAT SUCH- PEOPLE WOULD RECEIVE
WOULD CERTAINLY AS WE KNOW WHAT
THE COST OF LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA. WOULD NOT BE
ADEQUATE TO FULLY SUPPORT
YOURSELF BUT MIGHT JUST BE THAT
THING. THAT ENSURES THAT YOU
DON'T BECOME HOMELESS OR THAT.
YOU CAN CONTINUE YOUR EDUCATION.
YES CENTER ON AYE BY DAY I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR THAT
ANSWER IN WITH THAT I ENCOURAGE
AN AYE VOTE ON AB ONE FIVE
THREE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. THINGS THAT NINE
CENTER SKINNER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO ADOPT THAT AS YOUR CLOTHES.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. BACKER ARE
YOU FOR JUST. BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTES THREE FIVE
DALLY I DODD FIVE TORONTO HI
EGGMAN AYE GLAZER. FIVE
GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE HERTZBERG
HI WITH SO I FURTADO I JONES I
KAMLAGER FIVE FLARED HI LEYVA I
LIMóN I MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ.
MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN. OCHO OF
BOTH I PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE
STERN. I AMBERG I LIKE CASTING
I WIENER I WILL HI. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES. FOR
JEFF I GROVE MELENDEZ. NIELSEN
I THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR DIED.
YES MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
I'VE GOT A PRETTY COOL
ANNOUNCEMENT- MY SON AND HIS
WIFE- DELIVERED- ARE ELEVENTH
GRAND CHILD LAST NIGHT AT TWO
THIRTY AM. NINE DIED BELTS
FOURTEEN OUNCES ALL AS WELL SO
THANK YOU. CONGRATULATIONS
SENATOR SENATOR DODD WERE VERY
VERY HAPPY FOR YOU. MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION. WE WILL MOVE
TO ITEM ONE THIRTY THREE.
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. CETERA
MADAM MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THIRTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES
SAWYER AN ACT RELATING TO
FATIMID DECLARING THEIR TO SEE
THEIR OF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY SENATOR REID THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT CALLING THIS BILL
REENACTS THE PROVISIONS OF LAW
THAT CRIMINALIZED ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT IN THE OPERATION
OF THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL PROPERTY CRIMES TASK
FORCE UNTIL JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY SIX THE BILL MAINTAINS
THE BALANCE BETWEEN TACKLING A
PERVERSE PROBLEM AND PRESERVING
PUBLIC SAFETY REFORMS BY
TARGETING SOPHISTICATED
OPERATIONS. RATHER THAN
PERSONAL THEFT OUT OF NECESSITY
SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE
AVAILABILITY OF THE ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT DESCRIPTION AS A
CRIMINAL OFFENSE AND THE C. H.
P. TASK FORCE. HAVE BEEN
EFFECTIVE IN BUSTING RETAIL
THEFT RINGS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND FRANKLY RECOVERING
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF PROPERTY- MAINTAINS
THESE VITAL TOOLS THAT HAVE
HELPED US COLLECTIVELY RECOVER
AS I SAID MILLIONS AND MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS. AND DISRUPT THESE
LARGE RETAIL THEFT RINGS
OPERATING THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR- VOTE. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM SENATOR NIELSEN. HI
SUPPORTERS MEASURE BUT I WOULD.
I GUESS ACADEMICALLY REMIND OUR
MEMBERS THAT A VERY UNFORTUNATE
PROPOSITION PROPOSITION FORTY
SEVEN. CONSOLIDATED AND
ENCOURAGED SUCH STEP. TO THE
EXTENT NOW THAT SOME LARGE
RETAILERS ARE CLOSING THEIR
STORES BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN
LOSING SO MUCH AS A RESULT OF
PROP FORTY SEVEN
DECRIMINALIZING. THE STAFF.
THIS MARCH INTO THE STORAGE
PICK UP EVERYTHING THEY WANT
MARCH OUT. IF IT'S UNDER A HOT
NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS
BECAUSE F PROP FORTY SEVEN YOU
DO NOT HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT ANY
CONSEQUENCE. SO IF YOU WOULD
HAVE A CULPRIT HERE. PROP FORTY
SEVEN DESERVES THE DISCREDIT.
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SINGMAN CENTER UP YOU
MAY CONCLUDE ASSEMBLY US FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS. I
BATES I BAKER. I PORCHES I
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO HIGH
COURT HEAVY I DALY. I DODD AYE
TORONTO I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG HI
WITH SO. HI FURTADO I JONES I
KAMLAGER I LAYERED. I LEYVA I
LIMóN I MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S
AYE MIN. I NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN
AYE A TOTAL OF BOTH AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. I RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN AYE I'M BURKE I
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER. FIVE
WILK HI. FIVE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE BY I THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO ON URGENCY I
THIRTY NINE KNOWS ARE ON THE
BILL THE BILL PASSES. WHEN
PRESIDENT REQUEST IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE ASSEMBLY
THANK YOU SO ORDERED. MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN SEVENTY THREE SENATOR
CORTESE SB THREE HUNDRED ON
SENATE THIRD READING MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE HUNDRED BY SENATOR
CORTEZ SEE AN ACT RELATING TO
CRIMES AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY VERUS EXPECT
IMMEDIATELY CENTER CORTESE THE
FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT TO- AND COLLEAGUES I
RISE TO PRESENT SB THREE
HUNDRED THE SENTENCING REFORM
ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
CURRENT CALIFORNIA LAW MANDATES
A SENTENCE OF DEATH. FOR LIFE
WITHOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF
PAROLE I'LL WALK. FOR ANYONE
CONVICTED OF MURDER WITH
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES EVEN IF
THE PERSON DID NOT KILL ANYONE
NOR INTEND FOR ANYONE TO DIE.
ADDITIONALLY FOR ALL CRIMES IN
THE SENTENCING SCHEME. IF ANY
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES BROWN TO
BE TRUE. THE JUDGE HAS NO
CHOICE BUT TO SEND THE PERSON
TO DEATH OR L. WALK. CURRENT
LAW FORBIDS THE JUDGE FROM
CONSIDERING. WHETHER THOSE
PUNISHMENTS ARE FAIR BASED ON
THE FACTS IN ANY GIVEN CASE.
THE MANDATED MINIMUM. THE LAW
IS TO DIE BEHIND PRISON WALLS
WITHOUT ANY MEANS OF EARNING
PAROLE. THE SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES SENTENCING SCHEME
WITH WAX EVEN MINIMAL JUDICIAL
DISCRETION REFLECTS THE WORST
TENDENCIES WITHIN OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND
OVERWHELMINGLY IMPACTS PEOPLE
OF COLOR WHICH IS WHAT
ORIGINALLY CAUGHT MY ATTENTION
BUT ATTENTION. AND SEEN THAT
ISSUE OF FOCUS ME ON THE
CORRECTION I THINK THAT NEEDS
TO BE MADE TODAY MORE THAN TWO
THIRDS OF PEOPLE SERVING ALL
WHAT CALIFORNIA ARE BLACK OR
BROWN. THE VAST MAJORITY HAD NO
PRIOR CRIMINAL RECORD BEFORE
BEING SENTENCED TO DIE IN
PRISON. MOST FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE IN FACT THE AVERAGE
AGE OF THE TIME WE INTRODUCE
THIS BILL IS NINETEEN YEARS OLD.
SB THREE HUNDRED WOULD SEEK TO
FIX THIS OVERSIGHT IN OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM BY
PREVENTING SOMEONE WHO IS NOT
THE ACTUAL KILLER AND DOESN'T
HAVE AN INTENT TO KILL. BEFORE
BEING PUNISHED BY DEATH OR L.
WHAT. IF THE JUDGE. DECIDES IN
THE SENTENCING HEARING BUT THAT
THERE ARE MITIGATING
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR THAT
INDIVIDUAL I WANT TO EMPHASIZE-
IN I WILL PROBABLY AGAIN BEFORE
THIS PRESENTATION IS OVER THE
PENAL CODE ONE NINETY IS
REMAINS UNCHANGED. PENAL CODE
ONE NINETY IS THE STATUTE. THAT
GOVERNS BUT THE ISSUE OF A OF
THE MURDER OF A POLICE OF A
POLICE OFFICER. IN THE STATE
THERE IS NOTHING IN THIS BILL.
WHICH ALLOWS ANY KIND OF CHANGE
IN SENTENCING- THE PENAL CODE
ONE NINETY. THAT IS ALL WE'RE
TRYING TO CORRECT THE GOING
BACK TO. THE ISUE AT HAND HERE
WORK WE'RE SIMPLY TRYING TO
CORRECT. WHAT I THINK WAS AN
OVERSIGHT. OF WHEN THIS LAW
BECAME LAW. IN TERMS OF NOT
ALLOWING JUDICIAL DISCRETION IN
CASES BUT HE WAS A MAY BE-
WHERE AN ACCOMPLICE WAS
COMMANDEERED. YOUR TRAFFIC TO
WORK- IN SOME OTHER BUT LIKE
CIRCUMSTANCES BUT LITERALLY DID
NOT. RISE TO THE CRIMINAL
INTENT. OF THE PRIMARY SUSPECT.
RECENT AMENDMENTS HAVE REMOVED.
THE RESENTENCING LANGUAGE FROM
THIS BILL. WE REMOVED ANYTHING
RETROACTIVE FROM THE BILL OF
COLLEAGUES HAVE ASKED ME A TO.
ADD EXPRESS LANGUAGE THAT SAYS.
NOT ONLY IS THERE NO
RETROACTIVE RESENTENCING BUT
THAT THIS BILL IF WE PASS THIS
PASSED AND SIGNED INTO LAW.
WILL ONLY APPLY TO NEW CASES
FROM JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO ON THAT- OBVIOUSLY A
CLARIFIES ANY ISSUE ABOUT CASES
IN THE PIPELINE RIGHT NOW IN OF
WHETHER OR NOT THE LEGISLATURE
INTENDED TO COME IN AND MODIFY
ANY SPECIFIC CASES THAT MAY BE
PENDING WELL WE SPEAK. BUT THAT
IS NOT THE INTENT OF YOU HAVE
MY COMMITMENT THAT WE WILL.
INSTALL THE JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWO
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL.
ADDITIONALLY WITH BAD LANGUAGE
TO INDICATE THAT IS NOT OUR
INTENT. TO DISSUADE OR
INTERFERE WITH THE PROSECUTION
OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
ORCHESTRATED. BY BY WAY OF
CONSPIRACY OR OTHER MEANS-
OTHER THAN IMPUTED- IMPUTED
FELONY MURDER SO. GREAT
QUESTION I THINK IT'S BEEN
ASKED AND ANSWERED IN AGAIN
WITH WORKING WITH COLLEAGUES
SOME WE HAVE A COMMITMENT AS
THIS BILL MOVES ON TO THE OTHER
HOUSE TO MAKE IT. RETRACT
RETRACT OR TAKE AWAY. FROM THE
HIGH LEVEL CRIMINAL INTENT THAT
YOU SEE IN IN CONSPIRACIES AND
OTHER ORCHESTRATIONS OF OVER
THE PAST DECADE. CALIFORNIA
VOTERS IN THE LEGISLATURE OF
TAKEN IMPORTANT STEPS. TO
CORRECT IMPORTANT LANGUAGE
INVOLVING PUNISHMENT AND
IMPRISONMENT INCLUDING FOR
PEOPLE SERVING LONG SENTENCES
FOR SERIOUS CRIMES. I THINK
THESE REFORMS HAVE BENEFITTED-
AND EVEN ADDED TO THE SAFETY OF
OUR COMMUNITIES BY RETURNING
PEOPLE TO THEIR FAMILIES
EVENTUALLY IN FREEING UP FUNDS
A COMMUTER BESTED IN ADDRESSING
COMMUNITY NEEDS INCLUDE EMAIL
CALL JOB TRAINING EDUCATION.
THIS BILL MAINTAINS THE THAT
CURRENT LEGISLATIVE COURSE OF
JUSTICE- I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
ONE MORE THING BYE BYE TALK
ABOUT PENAL CODE ONE NINETY- IN.
A STATED HERE ON THE RECORD-
THAT OF THE MRDER OF A POLICE
OFFICER IS LITERALLY EXEMPTED
FROM THIS BILL. WE WILL PUT
MORE EXPRESS LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL THE STATE THAT CLEARLY AND
IN A SINGLE SENTENCE OVER AND
BEYOND WHAT OTHER LANGUAGE
ALREADY SAYS FIGHTING BACK THE
PENAL CODE ONE NINETY. BUT IN
THE LASTLY- I KNOW THERE'S BEEN
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT WHETHER
THIS IS A SENTENCING BILL- OR
WHETHER IT'S SOMEHOW INTENDS
TO- VOID OR VITIATE A
CONVICTION- THE LATTER IS NOT
THE CASE IT'S ABOUT SENTENCING-
DISCRETION FOR THE JUDGE WHERE
THERE'S EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES AND I'M HAPPY TO-
SPEAK ON THE RECORD ABOUT THAT
IF THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS- IN
THAT REGARD. BUT WITHOUT MADAM
PRESIDENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE IN SUPPORT AS A PROPER CO
AUTHOR OF SB THREE HUNDRED I
WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR FROM
SAN JOSE FOR HIS I WRK ON THIS
ISSUE ON CALIFORNIA'S FELONY
MURDER RULE ALTHOUGH WE'VE
NARROWED IT IS STILL UNSEEMLY
OVERBROAD I STILL REMEMBER THE
FIRST YEAR LAW STUDENT- IN OUR
OUR CRIMINAL LAW CLASS LEARNING
ABOUT THE SCALE OF THE FELONY
MURDER RULE. AND BEING TESTED
SHOCKS ABOUT HOW BROAD IT WAS
AND HOW PEOPLE COULD LITERALLY
GO TO JAIL FOREVER EVEN THOUGH
THEY DID NOT THEMSELVES KILL
ANYONE OR MAY NOT EVEN HAVE
KNOWN THAT SOMEONE WAS GOING TO
DIE HOW COULD THAT BE POSSIBLE
AND HOW COULD THAT BE PART OF
IT JUST PROCESSES SYSTEM. I IS
A ROLE- I THANK THE SENATOR FOR
BERKELEY FOR HER WORK. IN
MAKING IT MORE RATIONAL BUT
THERE'S MORE WORK TO DO AND
THAT'S WHAT SB THREE HUNDRED.
FIVE DOLLARS. HI THIS IS SIMPLY
GIVES DISCRETION SERVICE
SOMEONE IS NOT HAVE TO SPEND.
THE REST OF THEIR LIFE NO
MATTER WHY. IN JAIL. IT DOES
NOT ELIMINATE THE PENALTIES. IT
SIMPLY GIVES JUDGES MORE
DISCRETION. TO DO WHAT WE WANT
JUDGES TO DO TO LOOK AT THE
FACTS OF THE CASE. I MAKE AN
EVALUATION. AND NOT JUST GO FOR
LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE WITH THE
JUDGE HAVING NO OTHER OPTION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE CENTER LEYVA. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT A GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB THREE HUNDRED I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS VERY HARD WORK ON THIS
BILL- THREE HUNDRED WOULD
ADDRESS AN INJUSTICE IN OUR
CRIMINAL SYSTEM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. MEMBERS VICTIMS OF
ABUSE ARE PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE TO BEING NEAR THEIR
ABUSERS VIOLENT ACTIVITY AND
ARE THUS OFTEN PROSECUTED AS
ACCOMPLICES. FOR EXAMPLE.
PACIFIC WAY A WOMAN A VICTIM OF
SEX TRAFFICKING SINCE SHE WAS
FOURTEEN YEARS OLD AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IN THE CONTEXT OF
ONGOING TRAFFICKING AS AN
ADULT. WAS WAITING IN THE CAR
WHEN UNBEKNOWNST TO HER HER
ABUSER THE TRAFFIC- TRAFFICKER
SILVA MA'AM. SHE WAS PROSECUTED
AND SENTENCED TO LIFE WITHOUT
PAROLE THE LAW. THOUGH POLICE
AND PROSECUTORS UNDERSTOOD THAT
SHE DID NOT KILL ANYONE BUT THE
JUDGE HAD NO CHOICE. AND EVEN
WORSE. HER USER WAS ACQUITTED
HER CASE EXEMPLIFIES A PATTERN
SEEN WITH WOMEN SENTENCED UNDER
THE FELONY MURDER SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCE LINE CALIFORNIA.
SB THREE HUNDRED WILL ENSURE
THAT LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE IS NOT
A MANDATORY MINIMUM FOR VICTIMS
OF VIOLENCE WE DID NOT HARM OR
INTENT TO HARM ANYONE. IT WILL
ALSO RESTORED JUDICIAL
DISCRETION WHICH WILL ALLOW
JUDGES TO CONSIDER CONTEXT OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE STATEMENTS OF
VICTIMS AND OTHER EVIDENCE WHEN
DETERMINING SENTENCING. SB
THREE HUNDRED WILL ENABLE
JUDGES TO LOOK AT THE WHOLE
PICTURE BUT THEY ARE NOT
MANDATED TO SENTENCE PEOPLE TO
PRISON TERMS THEY DO NOT THINK
OR JUST OR FAIR. THIS MEASURES
AN IMPORTANT REFORM FOR WOMEN
WHO WERE CONVICTED FOR DEADLY
ACTIONS OF THEIR ABUSERS WHILE
SURVIVING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
MEMBERS I REPRESENT TO PRISONS
IN MY HOME TOWN OF CHINO IN A
WOMEN'S PRISON IN CHINO MEN'S
PRISON. I'VE LIVED THERE MY
WHOLE LIFE AND WE ALWAYS JUST
SAW THE PRISONS AND IT WAS JUST
PART OF THE LANDSCAPE. ONCE I
BECAME ELECTED I STARTED TO
UNDERSTAND SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WERE REALLY HAPPENING
THERE. AND I WOULD INVITE ANY
OF YOU WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO
WITH ME ON A TOUR AND ST DOWN
AND TALK TO THE GOLDEN GIRLS.
MANY OF THESE GOLDEN GIRLS HAVE
FALL FALL UNDER L. WALKER IN
THE LATE SIXTIES EARLY
SEVENTIES SOME EVEN IN THE
EARLY EIGHTIES. AND IT'S BEEN
ALMOST A LIFETIME IN JAIL.
UNDER THIS. THIS LAW. SO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO MEET SOME OF THEM
AND UNDERSTAND WHY THIS WOULD
HAVE HELPED THEM SO MUCH I'M
HAPPY TO SET THAT UP. THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING WE CAN DO TODAY
IS VOTE HI ON SB THREE HUNDRED.
SENATOR NIELSEN. NOT A PRESENT
LADIES ON THE SENATE I WILL
OPPOSE THE BILL AND REQUEST
THAT MANY OF YOU CONSIDER A
NOBLE. THIS IS ABOUT JUSTICE
AND JUSTICE INCLUDES THE
VICTIMS. NOW A LATER ON BETTER
THE FELONY MURDER RULE HAS
PERFECT. AND INDEED IT DOESN'T
MEAN THE ONE THAT SIMPLY PULLED
THE TRIGGER. THE CIRCUMSTANCES
UNDER WHICH A LOT OF THESE
HEINOUS CRIMES OCCUR. A WELL
PLANNED. MAYBE ON SOME RARE
OCCASION THERE'S AN ADVERT AN
EMERGENCY THAT SOMEONE ELSE
HAPPENS TO BE ALONG FOR THE
RIDE IF YOU WILL. BUT I
REVIEWED HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
OF THESE CASES LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN. AT THE ERRORS THAT
MAY BE HAVE OCCURRED ARE RARE I
ASSURE YOU. BUT THE PENALTY IS
A JUST WANT LIFE WITHOUT
POSSIBILITY OF PAROLE. AND YOU
HAVE TO KNOW SOMETHING THERE
REALLY IS NO SUCH THING AS THAT
SENTENCE WHY. THIS BUDGET
DASCHLE DECISION OR BY
LEGISLATIVE ACTION AS AN HERE
IS PROPOSED. THAT CIRCUMSTANCE
CAN CHANGE THAT INDIVIDUAL. FOR
EXAMPLE WE HAVE A DEATH PENALTY
IN CALIFORNIA. BY THE VOTERS
REAFFIRMED JUST A FEW YEARS AGO
BY THE VOTERS. BUT WE HAVE A
GOVERNOR WHO JUST MADE A
UNILATERAL DETERMINATION THERE
WILL BE NO EXECUTIONS. IN THE
STATE. IN OTHER WORDS THAT HIS
OPINION. OVERRULED THE
OVERWHELMING VOTERS OF THE
STATE. LIFE WITHOUT POSSIBILITY
OF PAROLE I ARGUE SHOULD REMAIN
AS IT IS BECAUSE OF THE HEINOUS
NESS OF THE CRIME THAT WAS
COMMITTED THAT THAT INDIVIDUAL
WAS INVOLVED IN. AND THE IMPACT
TO THE VICTIMS AND HE WILL TALK
TO SOMEBODY. TALK TO THE VICTIM
IS THE MOTHER. THE FATHER. THE
BROTHER THE SISTER. OF THAT
INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS MURDERED. IT
ALSO STUDY THE CIRCUMSTANCES
YOURSELF OF WHAT THE VICTIM WAS
SUBJECTED TO BY THOSE
INDIVIDUALS OR THAT INDIVIDUAL
WHO COMMITTED THAT CRIME.
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS SO WE
IN THE LEGISLATURE. IN
CALIFORNIA TOOK THE FIRST STEP
TO. ADJUST CALIFORNIA'S VERY
UNFAIR FELONY MURDER LAW WITH
SB FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN AND MY
CO AUTHOR AND I AUTHORED THE
BILL MY A CO AUTHOR WAS OUR SAN
DIEGO SENATOR JOEL ANDERSON.
AND HE CO AUTHORED THE BILL
WITH ME BECAUSE HE UNDERSTOOD
FUNDAMENTALLY THAT OUR FELONY
MURDER LAW. WAS UNFAIR. AND
LET'S BREAK IT DOWN. YOU CAN BE
THE MURDER. CAN BE CHARGED WITH
FIRST DEGREE MURDER. AND THEN
BE SENTENCED FOR FIRST DEGREE
MURDER. AND YOU CAN RECEIVE A
LOWER SENTENCE ANY PERSON WHO.
I DID NOT COMMIT THE MURDER DID
NOT PLAN THE MURDER DID NOT
HIRE SOMEONE TO DO THE MURDER
DID NOT ORCHESTRATE THE MURDER.
BUT UNDER THE FELONY MURDER
RULE YOU COULD RECEIVE A HIGHER
SENTENCE NUMBER SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES WHICH WE ARE
CORRECTING WITH THIS. IN EFFECT
DURING TEES BUT YOU GET THAT
SENTENCE THE JUDGE HAS NO
DISCRETION WHATSOEVER. MURDER
IN THE FIRST DEGREE THE JUDGE
HAS SOME DISCRETION. WHICH IS
WHY THE JUDGE FACTORS THINGS
THAT RELATED TO THE MURDER AND
WHY THERE ARE SOME FOLKS MURDER
IN THE FIRST DEGREE YOU DO NOT
HAVETHE SAME SENTENCE. AS
THOSE WHO GET CHARGED WITH
THIS. SO IT'S KIND OF LIKE
RUSSIAN ROULETTE. BUT YOU. YOU
CAN I MEAN IT'S I'M GOING TO
MAKE A TERRIBLE ANALOGY BUT IN
A WEIRD WAY YOU'VE BEEN BETTER
OFF TO BE THE ACTUAL MURDER WE
DO NOT WANT TO INCENTIVIZE
MURDER. AND THIS ALLOWS BGA THE
DEFENSE. THE VICTIM'S FAMILY.
HOWEVER TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PERSON'S ROLE IN THE CRIME IS
WHAT'S CONSIDERED INDENT THE
SENTENCING IT DOES NOT LET
PEOPLE OFF THE HOOK IT DOES NOT.
AND THERE IS AN IRONY FOR AN
ILL LOGIC IN A PENAL CODE THAT
ALLOWS THE FIRST DEGREE MURDER
TO BE SENTENCED AT A LOWER
SENTENCE THEN THE PERSON UNDER
THIS FELONY MURDER SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES SO THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT THING TO CORRECT AND
YOU MIGHT SAY WELL RIGHT.
SENATOR FROM BERKELEY WHY DID
YOU NOT PUT THAT IN FOURTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN BECAUSE PASSED THE
AUTHOR POINTED OUT. THE
CORRECTION OF THIS SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCE SITUATION BECAUSE
OF A PROPOSITION REQUIRES THE
TWO THIRDS VOTE WHICH IS A HARD
BLOW TO GET. AND SO. I
INTRODUCED MY BILL WITH ONLY
ADDRESSING THE PORTION THAT
WASN'T IMPACTED BY THAT BECAUSE
I WANTED TO REALLY HAVE I
WANTED THE LEGISLATURE TO HAVE
A FULL DEBATE AND TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND THIS BILL ANY MURDER
RULE I'M NOT A LAWYER I DIDN'T
GO TO LAW SCHOOL SO I HAD NO
IDEA WHEN. AS I VISITED PRISONS
AND LEARNED ABOUT THESE
DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCES I HAD
NO IDEA THAT YOU COULD HAVE
SUCH A MINIMAL ROLE IN THE
CRIME AND YET RECEIVE A HIGHER
SENTENCE THAN THE ACTUAL MURDER.
AND SO UNDERSTANDING AND I'M
SURE MANY OF ALL OF YOU DID
NOT. THOSE OF YOU ATTENDED LAW
SCHOOL MAY UNDERSTAND IT WELL
BUT THOSE OF YOU DIDN'T I'M
SURE DOES IT WOULDN'T EVEN
OCCUR TO YOU. AND IN FACT WHEN
I SPOKE TO MY FAMILY AND
FRIENDS ABOUT MY BILL FOURTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN. THEY WERE ALSO
BLOWN AWAY THAT YOU THE
CALIFORNIA HAD SUCH A LAW THAT
COULD SHOW DISPROPORTIONATELY
THREE. B. THE PERSON IN IN IN
THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE CRIME.
SO I WANTED TO MAKE SURE. THAT
WE UNDERSTOOD THAT THIS BILL
ONLY COVERS THOSE PEOPLE
CHARGED WITH FELONY MURDER
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES WHO DID
NOT KILL. WHO DID NOT INTEND TO
KILL WHO DID NOT PLAN THE
MURDER WHO DID NOT HIRE SOMEONE
TO MURDER. WE DID NOT
COORDINATE THAT MURDER. AND
CHAU ORCHESTRATED. SO I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THE PEOPLE
FULLY UNDERSTOOD. THAT THIS
WOULD HAPPEN NERO APPLICATION.
AND WITHOUT AYE ELSEVIER AYE
VOTE. SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND I TO
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
COMMON SENSE MEASURE IF THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT JUSTICE IT WOULD
BE JUST US BLACK AND BROWN
PEOPLE FELT FACING LIFE WITHOUT
PAROLE JUSTICE HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH THIS KURT BARBARIC WAY
OF SENTENCING IT'S ONLY BLACK
AND BROWN AND POOR PEOPLE WHO
EVER GET THE SENTENCE YOU'LL
NEVER FIND A RICH PERSON ON
LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE AND WE'RE
ONE OF THE FEW STATES AND
COUNTRIES THE WHITE LOCK PEOPLE
UP. WELL FOR LIFE SPECIALLY
BABIES WE HAVE A LIFE WITHOUT
PAROLE. FOR FOLKS UNDER
EIGHTEEN HERE IN THE STATE WHEN
I CAME TO A LEGISLATURE AND
WE'VE BEEN FIGHTING TO CORRECT
THAT. BOB SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE
YOU HAVE. ARE LESS DEVELOPED
COUNTRIES WHO TREAT THEIR
PRISONERS FAR MORE HUMANE THAN
WE DO EVEN COUNTRIES WHO WILL
CUT YOUR HAND OFF FOR STEALING
WILL NOT LOCK YOU UP. FOR LIFE.
AND WE'RE FAR BEYOND. ACTING
LIKE THE SYSTEM GET OUT. OF
JAIL FREE CARD IT DOESN'T DO
THAT I CAN GIVE YOU EXAMPLE
AFTER EXAMPLE I HAD OPPORTUNITY
TO VISIT FOLSOM PRISON. THE
NUMBER YEARS AGO. AT EVERYONE
WHO APPROACH ME WHO IS FACING
LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE WERE
BLOCKING BROWN INDIVIDUALS AND
THERE WERE INDIVIDUALS WHO
SIMPLY WERE AT THE WRONG PLACE
AT THE WRONG TIME. AND THEY'VE
HAD THEIR LIVES THROWN AWAY. AT
THE WRONG PLACE AT THE WRONG
TIME I TALK TO PLEASE WE DIDN'T
PULL THE GUY AND I ME PULL THE
TRIGGER DID NOT HAVE THE KNIFE
JUST HAPPEN TO BE IN THE CAR.
WHEN THE CRIME WAS COMMITTED OR
WAS SITTING IN THE CAR SOMEONE
WENT INTO A STORE SHOT SOMEONE
JUMPED IN THE CAR- BUT NO TO
THE ON THEIR DRIVING UP AND OUR
STUFF AND THEY GET CHARGED WITH
AIDING IN A BAG BETTY SILVA. I
THINK THE SENATOR PER OF SAN
JOSE FOR THIS MEASURE I THINK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY WHO
HAS WORKED HARD ON THIS ISSUE
FOR A LONG TIME. AND IF IT'S
REALLY. ABOUT JUSTICE THEN
LET'S HAVE A VOTE. ON THIS
THANK YOU. SENATOR GLAZERS.
THANK YOU- MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS- I FIRST WANT TO SAY TO
THE AUTHOR THAT I HAVE I HAVE
SUCH RESPECT FOR- HIS WORK IN
THIS VERY DIFFICULT AREA AT
THE- AT THE CRIMES THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH ARE ARE THE MOST
HORRIFIC. AND THE CONSEQUENCES
ARE THE MOST PROFOUND FOR
EVERYONE THE VICTIM'S FAMILY
THE PERSON ACCUSED AND IT IS A
VERY- I FIND IT TO BE THE- ONE
OF THE HARDEST PARTS OF
LEGISLATING IT IS IN THIS SPACE
AND I SO APPRECIATE YOUR- YOUR
WORK IN THIS AREA. AND I
APPRECIATE THE NARROWING THAT
YOU'VE DONE IN THIS BILL. I'D
LIKE TO ASK THE AUTHOR- A
COUPLE QUESTIONS IF I MAY NOT A
PRESIDENT. SENATOR CASEY WOULD
YOU TAKE A QUESTION YES MEMBERS
OF. OUR GOOD FOR SHAPE THAT. IT
THE BILL ADDRESS ADDRESSES.
ACTUALLY ELIMINATES A STANDARD-
THAT- IS A SIGNIFICANT
STANDARD- IN THE PROSECUTION
AND POTENTIALLY THE SENTENCING
OF AN INDIVIDUAL THAT STANDARD
IS THAT. IT'LL AND THIS IS WHAT
GETS LIMITED IN UNDER YOUR BILL.
THAT THE PERSON ACTED WITH
RECKLESS INDIFFERENCE FOR HUMAN
LIFE. AS A MAJOR PARTICIPANT.
IN CERTAIN VIOLENT FELONIES
THAT THE LANGUAGE THAT YOUR
BILL ELIMINATES INSERT AND SOME
CASES AND I'D LIKE YOU TO
ADDRESS THE THIS QUESTION ABOUT
THE ELIMINATION OF THAT
LANGUAGE WILL THAT AFFECT IN
ANY WAY. THE PROSECUTION. OF A
PERSON. UNDER THAT STANDARD.
NOT JUST THE SENTENCING ISSUE
WHICH WILL GET TO NEXT BUT THE
PROSECUTION IS DOES YOUR BILL
IN ANY WAY LIMIT THE ABILITY TO
GO AFTER A PERSON. UNDER THAT
STANDARD. THE FIRST WELL THANK
YOU SENATOR FOR THE QUESTION
IN- THE OPPORTUNE TO CLARIFY.
BUT NO IT DOES NOT THE RECKLESS
INDIFFERENCE. STANDARD IS
ESSENTIALLY- WERE ACCOMPLICES
UNDER SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES ARE
BEING CONVICTED OF FIRST DEGREE
MURDER. AS MY COLLEAGUE THE
FROM BERKELEY A POINTED OUT
THIS BILL DOESN'T CHANGE MORE
THAN INTENDED TO CHANGE- THE-
THE PROSECUTION- FOR FIRST
DEGREE MURDER OF THOSE
ACCOMPLICES WHAT IT INTENDS TO
DO AS Y. EMPHASIZE IT WAS A
SENTENCING BILL IN MY
PRESENTATION- IS GIVE THE JUDGE
IF THERE IS. IF THERE IS- A
CONVICTION. UNDER THAT STANDARD
THAT YOU JUST RAISED. THAT THE
JUDGE CAN TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
TOTALITY OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES
IN CASE IT IS A SITUATION LIKE
WE HEARD IN SOME OF THE OTHER
TESTIMONY. WHERE SOMEONE WAS
COMMANDEERED- WHERE THEY WERE
CONVICTED EVEN THOUGH THEY WERE
CONDUCT COMMANDEERED ARE
TRAFFICKED OR THERE WERE SOME
OTHER EXTENUATING
CIRCUMSTANCES. BUT IT SIMPLY IS
FOCUSED ON THE SENTENCING PHASE
OF THE TRIAL THE ACTUAL
SENTENCING HEARING AND REALLY
ALLOWS DEFENSE TRYING TO COME
FORWARD AND SAY- YOUR HONOR-
WE'D LIKE YOU TO CONSIDER THE
FACT. OF THE DESPITE THE
CONVICTION OF MY CLIENT BUT DID
NOT HAVE THE SAME LEVEL OF
CRIMINAL INTENT AS THE OTHER
PARTICIPANTS PERHAPS- IN THIS
MURDER. WHATEVER WE NEED TO DO
TO TAKE THAT CONFUSION OF THE
BILL AND MAKE WHAT I JUST SAID
EXPRESSED IN THE BILL- YOU HAVE
MY COMMITMENT THAT WILL DO
THAT. I APPRECIATE THAT AND
THAT REALLY GOES TO MY SECOND
QUESTION BECAUSE IN THE BILL
ITSELF. HI THIS IS ON PAGE
THREE LINE SIXTEEN IT SAYS
THIS. IT IS THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE. TO LIMIT THE
APPLICATION. OF SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES TO ACCOMPLISH IS.
WHO ACTED WITH INTENT TO KILL.
SAY THAT THAT'S WHAT THAT'S THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL NOW SO
COULD YOU LARIFY THAT LANGUAGE
THAT IN REGARD TO WHAT YOU JUST
PREVIOUSLY SAID IN A IN IN
BASED ON WHAT MY COMMITMENT
JUST WAS- AT THE RISK OF TRYING
TO AMEND THE BILL- WITH EXACT
LANGUAGE TODAY I DON'T. I'M
PROBABLY NOT QUALIFIED TO DO
THAT. WITH THAT LANGUAGE. THAT
LIMITATION- IS REALLY AN
EXPANSION IT MEANS THE WORDING
IS TO BE CHANGED TO ALLOW- THE
JUDICIAL DISCRETION. IN THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THE
CRIMINAL INTENT ROSE TO THE
LEVEL. OF RECKLESS
INDIFFERENCE. YEAH IT'S JUST
NOT THE DANGER ANSWER THAT'S ON
SENTENCING NOW YES THAT
LANGUAGE IS INTENDED TO ONLY
APPLY TO SENTENCING NOT THE
PROSECUTION. THAT'S CORRECT
VERY GOOD AND ONE FINAL.
QUESTION IF I MAY. THAT IF THE
JUDGE AND THIS IS A JUDGE- IN
REAL TIME GOING FORWARD IF YOU
CLARIFIED THAT THE START DATE.
OF JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWO.
BUT IF THE JUDGE IN THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES GOING FORWARD.
WERE TO COME TO THAT CONCLUSION
THAT THAT. STANDARD THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE ELIMINATING AS
APPLICABLE. WHAT IS THE MINIMUM
THAT I JUDGE COULD- SENTENCE
THAT INDIVIDUAL TO. WEAR THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES TO ARISE. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS AGAIN THERE
WOULD STILL BE A MURDER
CONVICTION AT THAT POINT. AS
YOU AS- AS YOU GO INTO THE
SENTENCING PHASE OF THE TRIAL
IN MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
WOULD TYPICALLY BE. A MINIMUM
OF TWENTY FIVE TO LIFE BUT WITH
THE POSSIBILITY OF PAROLE. OKAY
AND FINALLY I APPRECIATE AGAIN
YOUR CLARIFICATION. IF THE
JUDGE IN THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES-
UNDER YOUR BILL WERE TO MAKE
THAT FINDING. AND- ESTABLISH A
SENTENCE AT A MINIMUM OF TWENTY
FIVE YEARS TO LIFE- THAT PERSON
WOULD STILL BE SUBJECT TO ALL
THE PAROLE. REQUIREMENTS IN OUR
STATE MEANING THAT THEY COULD
APPLY AT SOME POINT. AND WHEN
THEY- SERVE THE MINIMUM FOR
PAROLE AND THAT A PAROLE BOARD
WOULD BE ABLE TO EXAMINE- ALL
THE CIRCUMSTANCES INCLUDING THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THEIR TIME IN
PRISON THEIR GOOD BEHAVIOR
ETCETERA TO. EVEN MAKE A
DETERMINATION AS TO WHETHER THE
NOT JUST THAT THEY'RE ELIGIBLE
BUT THAT THEY WOULD BE ALLOWED
AT SOME POINT TO GO ON PAROLE
IS THAT RIGHT. THAT'S CORRECT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SENATOR
MELENDEZ. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THE ORIGINAL FORM OF THIS BILL.
AS A BASIS FOR PEARL FERNANDEZ
THE MOTHER OF GABRIEL FERNANDEZ
THE BASIS FOR HER TO
CONTEMPLATE ASKING FOR
RESENTENCING AS YOU RECALL
GABRIEL FERNANDEZ WAS AN EIGHT
YEAR OLD LITTLE BOY WHO WAS
TORTURED. BEATEN NEGLECTED AND
ALTERNATELY MURDERED BY PEARL
FERNANDEZ'S BOYFRIEND.
GABRIEL'S MOTHER PEARL
FERNANDEZ MOST CERTAINLY
PARTICIPATED IN ALL OF THESE
ACTIONS THAT TOOK A GABRIEL'S
LIFE THERE SHE DIDN'T COMMIT
THE FINAL BLOW THAT TOOK HIS
LIFE. SO WHILE I APPRECIATE
THAT THE AUTHOR HAS TAKEN OUT.
THE PARTS OF THE BILL THAT
WOULD MAKE IT RETROACTIVE GOING
FORWARD WHAT IT WILL STILL
ALLOW S FOR SOMEONE. WHO
COMMITS CRIMES LIKE PEARL
FERNANDEZ DID CAUSING THE DEATH
OF HER SON. TO RECEIVE THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT IN THE
CASE WHICH I BELIEVE- SHOULD
NOT EXIST THIS. AT I'M BEGGING
YOU TO DEEPLY CONSIDER WHAT
YOU'RE ABOUT TO DO AND THINK OF
THE GABRIEL FERNANDEZ'S OF THE
WORLD WHO MAY- BECOME.
VICTIMLESS IN THE FUTURE OF.
THEIR PARENT OR THEIR PARENTS
BOYFRIEND OR GIRLFRIEND- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOVA. IS
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF. SINGMAN
CENTER CORTESE ME YOU MAY
CONCLUDE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- LET ME- ONCE AGAIN-
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BERKELEY FOR- HOME FOUNDATIONAL
WORK AND MORE THAN FOUNDATIONAL
WORK BUT THE SIGNIFICANT WORK
BY THAT HELP SO MUCH TO GET US
TO THIS POINT- FOR HER EFFORTS
TODAY- FOR ALL THOSE WHO SPOKE.
IN SUPPORT TODAY FOR THOSE
COLLEAGUES WHO DIDN'T SPEAK-
WORKING ME VERY CLOSELY- TO GET
THE LANGUAGE RIGHT- TODAY TO
PRESENT TODAY A AND TWO OF THE
CO AUTHORS. OF WHO HAVE COME ON
IN THOSE WHO INDICATED LIKE TO
COME ON TO THE BILL I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL- AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. ADAM
CHECK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA ATKINS AYE
BATES NO BACKER I FOR JUST. NO
BRADFORD. HI CABALLERO. CORTESE
FIVE DALLY NO DODD I THERE ARE
SO I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROW HERTZBERG FIVE
HUESO ARE YOU FURTADO. JONES NO
KAMLAGER I GLARED I LEYVA I
LIMóN I MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ
NO MAN AYE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN.
NO A SHOW OF BOTH NO HAN. I
PORTANTINO. I ROTH. I RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER AYE STERN I AMBERG
LAKE COUNTY FIVE WIENER AYE
WILK NO. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ARCHULETA CABALLERO.
GLAZER I GROVE. HER TADO.
AMBERG. HIS TWENTY SEVEN NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY IS TWENTY
SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE I AM SORRY
ZERO HE KNOWS EIGHT ARE ON THE
MEASURE THE MEASURE PASSES.
SORRY GUYS- WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON. HI KATIE- MESSAGES
FROM THE ASSEMBLY MADAM COLOR
PLEASE READ. MADAM PRESIDENT I
AM DIRECTED TO INFORM YOUR
HONORABLE BODY THAT THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDED AND ON THIS
DAY PASSED AS AMENDED SENATE
BILLS ONE FORTY FOUR ONE FIFTY
SIX AND IS SENATE BILL ONE
SIXTY. AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR HONORABLE BODY TO
CONCURRENCE THAT AMENDMENTS TO
PARKER CHIEF CLERK OF THE
ASSEMBLY ABOVE BILLS ORDER TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS FILE. THE
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
SET SENATE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE
ONE. UNFINISHED BUSINESS ITEM
NUMBER ONE FIFTY THREE WHICH IS
A BUDGET BILL FOR SENATE'S
HEALTH CENTER SKINNER- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. OKAY.
CORRECTION ON THAT SENATOR
PORTANTINO. IS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE THREE. SENATE BILL ONE
FORTY FOUR BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO AND AFTER RELATING
TO TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY SENATOR
PORTANTINO THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU- MADAM BOOK. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS- TODAY I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB ONE FOUR FOUR
WHICH IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
AND IT IS IMPORTANT MEASURE
WHICH EXPANDS THE CALIFORNIA
FILM A TAX CREDIT PROGRAM. WITH
AN EMPHASIS ON INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS AND WORKFORCE.
DIVERSITY I WANT TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR AND THE PRO TEM AND
BUDGET STAFF AND PRO TEM STAFF
FOR GETTING US TO THIS POINT-
THIS TRULY WAS- A COLLECTIVE
EFFORT- RECOGNIZING HOW
IMPORTANT. THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY IS TO THE HEALTH AND
WELFARE OF CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AS THE HERITAGE OF OUR GREAT
STATE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
INDUSTRY THAT GOES ACK OVER A
HUNDRED YEARS THAT IS PART OF
THE FABRIC OF CALIFORNIA AND-
CENTRAL TO OUR SUCCESS IS AN
ECONOMIC POWERHOUSE.
SIGNIFICANTLY THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE CONCURRING ON EXPAND
THE EXISTING TAX CREDIT BY
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
NEXT TWO YEARS THAT'S IMPORTANT
TO KNOW BECAUSE THE CURRENT TAX
CREDIT. HAS BEEN SO SUCCESSFUL-
THAT DEMAND FOR- BRINGING MORE
PRIDE PRODUCTIONS BACK
CALIFORNIA HAS EXCEEDED THE
AMOUNT THE PRE PREVIOUSLY
BUDGETED AND WE NEED THIS
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
NEXT TWO YEARS TO COVER. THAT
DEMAND. AND BY MEETING THAT
DEMAND WE'RE GOING TO INCREASE
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC VITALITY
AND HEALTH AND WELFARE OF OUR
STATE AS WE COME OUT OF THIS
PANDEMIC SIGNIFICANTLY. THE
BILL ALSO INCLUDES A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS. FOR
A NEW FILM INFRASTRUCTURE TAX
CREDIT WHICH ENCOURAGES
INVESTMENTS IN STUDIO AND
SOUNDSTAGES IN CALIFORNIA. THE
LIFE CYCLE OF A SOUND STAGE IS
A HUNDRED YEARS LET ME SAY THAT
AGAIN THE LIFE CYCLE OF A SOUND
STAGE IS A HUNDRED YEARS. SO
WHEN WE BUILD NEW SOUNDSTAGES
WE'RE BUILDING CAPACITY FOR THE
NEXT CENTURY THAT MEANS
GENERATIONS OF WORK FORCE
MIDDLE CLASS JOBS WILL WORK OUT
OF THESE NEW SOUND STAGES.
THAT'S A CRITICAL COMPONENT OF
THIS BILL AND AGAIN THE
BUILDING TRADES WERE A
SIGNIFICANT SUPPORTER. AND
INITIATOR OF THIS- PROPOSAL TO
CREATE THOSE JOBS BUILDING
THOSE SOUND STAGES AND THEN.
HAVING A PLACE FOR THAT
ENTERTAINMENT WORK FORCE. TO DO
THEIR TRADES FOR THE NEXT
CENTURY- ADDITIONALLY. THE BILL
REQUIRES. REPORTING RELATED TO
WORKFORCE DIVERSITY IN THE FILM
INDUSTRY THAT HAS LONG BEEN AN
IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF OUR
DISCUSSIONS UP HERE ABOUT HOW
DO WE MAKE THIS CORE-
CALIFORNIA INDUSTRY REFLECT
WHAT CALIFORNIA LOOKS LIKE IN
THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE. SO
THERE'S GOING TO BE DATA
COLLECTION RELATED TO THE
ORIGINAL TAX CREDIT AND THEN
THEY'RE GOING TO BE DIVERSITY
GOALS TIED TO THE NEW
PRODUCTION TAX CREDIT FOR THE
STUDIO PRODUCTION- AND WHAT'S
UNIQUE ABOUT THIS AND I HAVE TO
GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO MY
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WENDY CARILLO IS WE'RE ASKING
THE STUDIOS AND THE PRODUCTIONS
TO CREATE THEIR OWN GOALS AND
BENCHMARKS ON DIVERSITY AND
THEN THE CALIFORNIA FILM
COMMISSION WILL VERIFY THAT
THOSE GOALS. ARE MET- OVER THE
YEARS WE'VE SEEN MANY TAX
CREDITS THAT WERE USED TO-
DURING LATE NIGHT BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS BACK WHEN A TWO
THIRDS WAS REQUIRED. TO PASS A
BUDGET AND MANY OF THOSE TAX
CREDITS HAD NO ACCOUNTABILITY I
HAD NO WAY OF KNOWING IF THE
INTENDED PURPOSE WAS ACTUALLY
CREATED WHAT'S UNIQUE ABOUT THE
ENTERTAINMENT TAX CREDITS IS.
YOU ACTUALLY HAVE TO MAKE THE
PRODUCTIONS YOU ACTUALLY HAVE
TO BUILD THE STAGES YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE TO CREATE THE
JOBS BEFORE YOU EARN THOSE
CREDIT SO. FOR THOSE OF US WHO
CARE DEEPLY IN THIS BODY DOES
CARE DEEPLY ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND MEASUREMENTS
AND INDEPENDENT DATA THAT'S
EMBEDDED INTO THIS. PROGRAM AS
WELL AS FOR THE MONETARY
BENEFITS BUT ALSO ON THE
DIVERSITY BENEFITS- THIS IS.
EXTREMELY CRITICAL TO OUR STATE
WE'VE SEEN OVER THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS AND ACTUALLY AN ACCIDENT
THE FILM PRODUCTIONS AT A
CALIFORNIA TO THE SOUTH AND TO
THE NORTH- ARE INCENTIVES HAVE
BEEN SO SUCCESSFUL. THAT THEY
BROUGHT THOSE PRODUCTION- BACK
TO CALIFORNIA. SB FIVE ONE FOUR
FOUR BUILDS ON THE RESOUNDING
SUCCESS OF THESE TAX CREDITS-
WHICH ARE BROUGHT DOZENS OF
PRODUCTIONS BACK. TO WHERE THEY
BELONG THEY BELONG HERE WITH
US- IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE FORTY
FOR IS A BROAD COALITION OF THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY. AND
LABOR WHICH INCLUDES AS I SAID
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION-
IOTTIE COUNCIL MOTION PICTURE
ASSOCIATION THE DIRECTORS GUILD
OF AMERICA. SAG AFTRA ALLY YOU
KNOW LOCAL SEVEN TWENTY FOUR
AND THE TEAMSTERS LOCAL THREE
NINETY NINE SO THERE'S A BROAD
COALITION OF. MIDDLE CLASS
WORKING FAMILY JOB PRODUCING
PEOPLE THAT SUPPORT THIS
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT LET'S BRING A CORE
HISTORICAL INDUSTRY BACK TO
CALIFORNIA. LET'S MAKE IT
THRIVE CONTINUE TO THRIVE AND
AGAIN I WANT TO GIVE A BIG
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYBODY. WHO'S
MADE THIS HAPPEN TODAY OUR
PROGRAM WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
CREATING THE TAX CREDIT WHEN
SHE WAS SPEAKER. AND HER OFFICE
AND ARE BUDGET STAFF AND I
WANNA GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO OUR
BUDGET- CHAIR. MISKIN AND
EVERYONE WHO'S WORKED TO BRING
THIS- COLLECTIVELY TO PUT US ON
THE FLOOR TODAY. AS SOMEBODY
REPRESENTS BURBANK WHICH IS ONE
OF THE INDUSTRY- HUBS IN OUR
STATE I'M PROUD TO AUTHOR- SB
ONE FOUR FOUR AND ASK EVERYONE
TO VOTE ON THE CONCURRENCE
TODAY. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE CENTER WELL. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB ONE FORTY
FOUR THIS IS A GREAT ADDITION
TO THOUGH THE WORK- THAT
APPROACH HIM DEAD WHEN SHE WAS
SPEAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY HOW SHE
GOT GOVERNOR BROWN TO THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE BILLION
DOLLARS I HAVE NO IDEA HE DID
RELUCTANTLY BUT IT HAPPENED.
AND WHAT'S GREAT ABOUT THESE-
THESE NEW- ITEMS IN THIS
PARTICULAR BILL IS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE YOU KNOW- TEN
YEARS AGO THERE MAY HAVE BEEN A
HUNDRED A HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
DIFFERENT PRODUCTIONS GOING ON
AROUND THE WORLD TODAY IT'S
OVER TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED-
BECAUSE OF THE NEED FOR CONTENT
BECAUSE IT'S STREAMING SO THIS
IS KEEPING UP. WITH TECHNOLOGY
SECONDLY TO ME THIS IS A PRO
FAMILY BILL ARE YOU KNOW
BECAUSE WITH THE RUNAWAY FILM
PRODUCTION YOU KNOW MOM SINGING
KIDS WERE STAYING OUT AT HOME
AND DAD WAS IN GEORGIA- IN
NORTH CAROLINA WHAT HAVE YOU-
MY DISTRICT HAPPENS TO BE IN
THE TEAM SEE- RUNAWAY FILM
PRODUCTION CREATED A LOT OF
DIVORCES AND BROKEN FAMILIES.
AND FOR EVERYBODY TO BE ABLE TO
STAY TOGETHER WORK LIVE AND
THRIVE I THIS IS THIS IS GREAT
BECAUSE IT'S AN ICONIC INDUSTRY
FOR CALIFORNIA BUT IT'S EVEN
BETTER FOR FAMILIES I SALUTE
FATHER FIRST EFFORT ON THIS AN
ASPIRIN I VOTE. UBIO THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES
AT THE SENATE I ALSO WANT TO
SEND A STRONG SUPPORT AS A PAUL
COOPER TODAY'S MEASURE ON I
ALSO BELIEVE IN THE
ACCOUNTABILITY PIECE BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY THE DIVERSE CITY
PIECE WE DEFINITELY NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S PART OF
THE EQUATION I DO BELIEVE THAT
THE FILM INDUSTRY SUCH AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE FABRIC OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE WANT TO KEEP
PRODUCTION HERE BUT ALSO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE PEACEFUL CREEK
SO MANY GOOD PAYING JOBS WHICH
ARE ESSENTIAL DURING THIS TIME
WITH THAT I ALSO ASTRONOMICAL
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THING MAN
CENTER PORTANTINO YOU MAY
CONCLUDE- THANK YOU FOR THIS-
GREAT SUPPORT IN THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES I BAKER I FOR JUST
AYE BRADFORD AYE CABRERA AYE
CORTESE AYE DALLY AYE DODD. I
TORONTO I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH HERTZBERG AYE
HUESO I FURTADO I JONES I
KAMLAGER I LAYERED. I LEYVA AYE
LIMóN I MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ.
MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN. A
CHIRLA BOTH AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO AYE
SKINNER. I STERN AYE NUMBER
FIVE WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER
AYE WILK. HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GROSS MELENDEZ.
NIELSEN I THIRTY SEVEN NODE
ZERO THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED WITH MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER NUMBER ONE
FIFTY FOUR THE BUDGET BILL HAAS
CENTER SKINNER IS READY. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL ONE FIFTY SIX BY THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT RELATING
TO COMMUNICATIONS A MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. CENTER SKINNER
THE FOR MAKING VERY MUCH- MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I WANT TO
THANK THIS IS OUR BROADBAND
TRAILER BILL AND I REALLY WANT
TO THANK. THE WORKING GROUP
THAT THE PRO TEM ESTABLISHED
THAT WORKED VERY DILIGENTLY ON
THIS BILL INCLUDING OUR-
SENATOR FROM HEALDSBURG OUR
SENATOR FROM LONG BEACH OUR
SENATOR THAT NUMBER OF OTHER
SENATORS SO APOLOGIES IF I AM
NOT. TECHNOLOGY SEEING EACH ONE
OF YOU BUT I AM ACKNOWLEDGING
ALL OF YOUR GOOD WORK ON THIS.
AND IF WE EVER DOUBT WHETHER
INTERNET ACCESS IS AN ESSENTIAL
NEED THE PANDEMIC MORE THAN
DEMONSTRATED THE NECESSARY
NECESSITY EVERY CALIFORNIANS
HAVE RELIABLE ACCESS IN ORDER
TO FUNCTION IN TODAY'S WORLD
MORE MORE WE ALREADY KNEW THAT
WE WERE DEPENDENT ON THE
INTERNET FOR APPLYING FOR JOBS
APPLYING TO COLLEGE AND SUCH
BUT OF COURSE DURING THE
PANDEMIC. WE RELIED ON ENTIRELY
TO CONTINUE OUR EDUCATION
WHETHER WE WERE A KID OR ADULT
YOU NAME IT WE ALSO NEEDED TO
RELY ON IT FOR MUCH OF OUR
HEALTH CARE SO THAT WE CAN
AVOID HAVING TO GO TO A
HOSPITAL IF THE POPE IT WAS NOT
OUR ISSUE AND WE DID NOT WANT
TO GET COVERAGE SO WE WERE
USING THE INTERNET FOR OUR
OTHER HEALTHCARE NEEDS AND WHAT
DID AND WE ALSO WERE USING IT
TO ENSURE THAT OUR FAMILIES AND
HOUSEHOLDS AT THE FOOD AND THE
OTHER GOOD THING NEEDED. BUT
WHAT MADE IT OBVIOUS IN THE
PANDEMIC WHAT MANY OF US
ALREADY KNEW IS THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE IS GREAT AND NOT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE RELIABLE
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET FOR ANY
ACCESS AND WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
IS ENABLE US TO. PUTS THIS ON
THE AND THAT WE MADE IN THE
BUDGET BILL WE ADOPTED AND WITH
THE BENEFIT OF THE FEDERAL
FUNDS. IT CREATES THE ABILITY
TO CONSTRUCT THAT STATE WIDE
OPEN ACCESS MIDDLE MILE NETWORK
DISCOUNT WHICH IS A GOVERNMENT
STRUCTURE FOR THE PROJECT. IT
ALLOWS FOR A LOAN LOSS RESERVE
FOR OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
AID ENABLE THEM TO ISSUE BONDS
FOR THE CREATION OF A LOCAL
BROADBAND NETWORKS AND A WHOLE
LOT MORE AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. CENTER
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I TOO WOULD LIKE TO
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL- AS WE ALL HAVE KNOWN WE
AND AS OUR I'M CALLING FROM
BERKELEY AND MENTION THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLE CREDIBLE BELL- I
WANT TO THANK ALSO THE PAY PRO
TEM ARE SENATE LEADERSHIP
SENATE ENERGY AND BUDGET
COMMITTEES AND ARE GOOD
COLLEAGUES FROM HELD BURKE
SALINAS AND SAN DIEGO I WANT TO
THANK THEM FOR THEIR WORK THIS
NOT ONLY WILL SPUR A
COMPETITIVE ENVIRONMENT IN IN
CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO IN POWER
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN INTERNET.
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND WHICH ARE
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESSES OF
ALL SIZES TO HELP MODERNIZE OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE WILL BE
PARTS PRIORITIZING UNSERVED AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AGAIN
UNSERVED AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES WHILE ALSO
INVESTING IN CALIFORNIA
INNOVATION THIS IS SORELY
NEEDED WE HAVE WASTED DECADES
WITH THE STATUS QUO AND NOW
IT'S OUR TIME TO. ENABLE FUTURE
GENERATIONS TO HAVE ACCESS TO
NOT ONLY THE INTERNET ACCESS TO
HEALTH EQUITY ACCESS TO UPWARD
MOBILITY FOR ECONOMIC
EMPOWERMENT AND ACCESS OF
COURSE TO- UP INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITIES HERE IN OUR STATE
WE CANNOT LEAVE ANY CHILD ANY
SENIOR ANY FAMILY BEHIND. OUR
SPEC CLASS FOR NAVAL. SENATOR
WITH A- THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO AND SANDERS- FIRST
OF ALL I JUST WANT TO RATE RISE
AND JUST CELEBRATE THIS
WONDERFUL BUDGET THAT WE PUT
TOGETHER THIS IS TRULY HISTORIC
AND THIS BILL IS INCLUDED IN
WHAT IS REALLY HISTORIC YEAR
BUDGET WISE AND THIS BILL IS
GOING TO MAKE INVESTMENTS AND
IN IN OUR STATE THEY'RE REALLY
UNPRECEDENTED THIS IS REALLY A
NEW AND EXCITING. A PROGRAM
THAT WE'RE GONNA ROLL OUT IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S GOING TO
REALLY HELP CONNECT ALL OUR
COMMUNITIES WE'VE BEEN WORKING
HARD FOR MANY YEARS TO CONNECT
CALIFORNIA'S MOST UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND THAT PROCESS
HAS BEEN SLOW THIS INVESTMENT
IS GONNA SPEEDED UP ENORMOUSLY
SO I JUST WANTED RAISE UP MY
MIKE AND- IN SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS AND ALSO POINT OUT THAT
THE SENATE WAS VERY SUCCESSFUL
IN ESTABLISHING STRONGER
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES SO-
THEY'LL BE- MORE PARTICIPATION
AND LEGISLATURE TO MAKE SURE
THESE INVESTMENTS ARE MADE.
WHERE THEY'RE MADE AND- THEY'LL
BE MORE OVERSIGHT OF THE
PROGRAM AND I WANT TO THANK-
ARE ARE SENATORS A PARTICIPATE
IN THIS PROGRAM- CENTER
GONZALEZ CENTER MCGUIRE CENTER
COUPLE YET ON OF COURSE FOR OUR
ARE POTENTIALLY TO SHIP ON THIS
ISSUE COMMITTING THE GROUP
WORKING VERY HARD TO SORT THIS
OUT WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
SO. THIS IS. A WONDERFUL
PROGRAM AND I RECOMMEND I VOTE.
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I ONLY CHOSE
TO SPEAK ON TO BUILD TODAY AND
THIS IS ONE I THINK NEEDS TO BE
SPOKE ON. ME ASK YOU WHAT
GOVERNMENT DOES GOOD. WE HAVE
THE E. D. WE'RE HAVING PROBLEMS
WITH WE HAVE THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL WE'RE HAVING PROBLEMS WITH
THE DMV I T. PROJECTS. WATER
BOND WE CAN'T GET OUT FOR WATER.
LET ME TALK ABOUT THIS BILL.
THIS BILL. IT'S GOING TO BY
PASS THE PRIVATE COMPANIES AND
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING ABOUT
THE PRIVATE COMPANIES WE HAVE
DONUT HOLES AND WE HAVE THE
LAST MILE. THAT NEEDS TO BE
SERVED. SO WHAT ARE THE
LEGISLATURE DO THE LEGISLATURE.
WITH MY HEALTH AND MANY OTHER
OF YOU IN THIS ROOM PASSED.
EXTENDING FUNDS FOR CASTLE.
WHICH WOULD HELP THOSE PRIVATE
OWNED COMPANIES. GET TO THE
DONUT HOLES AND THE LAST MILES
IN CALIFORNIA AND WHAT DID THEY
DO. THIS IS WHAT THEY DID ZERO.
THEY DIDN'T ACCESS THE FUNDS.
THEY'RE ALSO THE ONES THAT WILL
TELL YOU THAT THIS IS GOING TO
FAIL. BECAUSE THEIR THEIR
PRIVATE COMPANIES AND ALL THEY
CARE ABOUT IS PROFITS. FOR
THEIR SHAREHOLDERS. THIS BILL.
SO IT IN AB THE TWENTY SIX
SIXTY FIVE. THE MONEY THAT THE
CAST THE FUNDS GO TO GO TO THAT
YOU SEE AND THEN NONPROFITS.
USE THAT MONEY AND THEY'RE
RETIRED LEGISLATORS. WHO HAVE
SET UP THESE NONPROFITS TO DO
THE BILL TO EXTEND THE MONEY
AND WHAT WE GET FOR THAT WE
GOT. ZERO NOW I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THINGS WHERE GOVERNMENT
WORKS. WE HAVE UTILITIES I
HAPPEN TO BE. A SMUG CUSTOMER
PG&E CUSTOMER AND- RULE
ELECTRIC COOP CUSTOMER AND OUT
OF THOSE THREE. THE ONE THAT
SERVES ME THE BEST IS MY COOPER
YOU KNOW WHY BECAUSE- I'M A
MEMBER WE OWN IT. WE'RE NOT FOR
PROFIT WE'RE FORGETTING THE
SERVICE TO. EACH OTHER IN A
POOL. OPPORTUNITY I WANT TO
TAKE THE- ASSEMBLY THE
LEADERSHIP- IT IS A PRO TEM. MY
WIFE FOR ACTUALLY PUTTING IN
THE LANGUAGE THAT WILL ALLOW
RULE COOPS AND UTILITIES TO BE
ABLE TO ACCESS THESE FUNDS THAT
IS SECTION FIVE SUBSECTION FIVE
THREE ONE SIX SEVEN. IN PLUMAS
COUNTY. VERY RULED COMMUNITY WE
HAVE HIGH SPEED NTERNET
IMAGINE THAT WHY. BECAUSE A
RULE ELECTRIC CAME IN AND PUT
IT IN. THE OTHER THING I WANT
TO MENTION THAT IN THIS BILL
THAT I'M EXPERTS CITED ABOUT.
IS THAT THEY'RE GONNA BE TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND TWO
SENATORS APPOINTED TO OVERSEE
THIS. AND I WILL SHARE WITH YOU-
I'M GONNA BE WATCHING THIS LIKE
A HAWK LIKE I'VE BEEN WATCHING
THE WILD FIRE MONEY. BECAUSE IF
YOU REALLY WANT TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN CALIFORNIA. WE
HAVE TO SEND A MESSAGE TO THE
UTILITIES THAT YOU KNOW WHAT
YOU CAN'T JUST CAN SIMPLY TELL
ME WHAT'S WRONG WITH MY BILL
WHEN I ASKED YOU. TO GIVE ME A
SOLUTION. NOT ONE OF THEM COULD
TELL YOU THIS IS HOW MUCH MONEY
MR DALLEY WE'RE GOING TO GET TO
GET THE LAST MILE. AND THE
DONUT HOLES AND THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE UNSERVED IN CALIFORNIA.
THERE'S A LOT MORE WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE ON THIS BILL.
WE'RE GONNA CAN CAN YOU TO SEE.
MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO FINE TUNE
IT. AND I WILL BE WATCHING
THAT. AND MANY OF YOU'VE HEARD
ME SPEAK ABOUT THE DEBT IN THIS
COUNTRY. AND WHAT THE FUTURE
LOOKS LIKE FOR OUR CHILDREN.
I'VE BEEN HERE NINE YEARS. AND
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO GET
INTERNET FOR MY COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THE STATE
WE CAN EDUCATE OUR CHILDREN WE
CAN HELP OUR OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE CAN HELP OUR
FIRE COMMUNITIES WE CAN HELP
OUR HOSPITALS OR SCHOOLS OR
LIBRARIES AND WE HAVE NOT GOT
ANYTHING EVEN THOUGH WE PUT THE
MONEY UP. SO MORE SO I WANT TO
SHARE THIS IS INVESTMENT. I
BELIEVE WE SHOULD MAKE IT'S
GOING TO TAKE A LOT OF HARD
WORK TO DO IT RIGHT. AND I'M
GONNA VOTE FOR THIS BILL TODAY.
BECAUSE I'M TIRED OF HEARING
FROM UTILITIES AND THOSE WHO.
ALWAYS CRITICIZE WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE DOES. BUT DOESN'T
HAVE A SOLUTION. AND WHEN THEY
SAY THEY WANT A SOLUTION. AND
WE GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE THAT DIFFERENCE THEY DON'T
TAKE IT. SO FOR THOSE REASONS I
WILL BE VOTING TO GET INTERNET.
AND BROADBAND TO OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT DESPERATELY
NEED IT AND IF ANYTHING ELSE
WE'VE SEEN DURING THIS TIME.
DURING THE PANDEMIC HOW
DESPERATELY WE NEEDED IN NOT
JUST THE ROLE PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S BUT THE URBAN
PARTS AS WELL. SOMEONE AGAIN
THANK THE PRO TEM THE SPEAKER.
THE SENATOR FROM LONG BEACH THE
SENATOR FROM SALINAS WHO HAVE
WHO'VE WEIGHED IN ON THIS AND
WORKED REAL HARD AND I'M GONNA
BE I WANT TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION I DON'T BELIEVE IN
BEING A LEGISLATURE THAT JUST.
LEGISLATOR THAT JUST **** ALL
THE TIME. I WANT TO DIG IN. AND
I WANT TO MAKE IT RIGHT. SO I'M
HERE AT YOUR SERVICE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ACTUALLY GET
INTERNET. TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
THANK YOU. SENATOR KAMLAGER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I TO-
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
AND I WANT TO THINK SENATORS
GONZALEZ AND CARREIRO AND
REQUIRING THE PRO TEM FOR
REALLY GUIDING THIS THROUGH TO
THIS FINISH LINE- AS THE
SENATOR FROM BEAVER STATED YOU
KNOW RURAL AND URBAN RESIDENTS
ALIKE- DESERVE THIS AND I THINK
THEY WILL BENEFIT TREMENDOUSLY
FROM THIS BUDGET BILL. IN THIS
DIGITAL ERA WE- BROAD IS
CRITICAL RIGHT. NOW THAT'S A
JOKE BUT THE TRANSLATION OF
THAT IS WE NEED THIS BILL
BECAUSE SO MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
HAVE HAD TO SUFFER THROUGH
DEALING WITH INTERNET SERVICE
DEALING WITH BROADBAND SERVICE
THAT CUTS OUT THAT IS
INCONSISTENT- THAT IS FRIED THE
HEADS OF THE HAIRS OF PROBABLY
ALMOST EVERY CALIFORNIAN IN
CALIFORNIA AND WHEN WE ARE
STRUGGLING WITH THE KINDS OF
CHALLENGES THAT WE ARE FACING
IN THIS STATE. CONNECTIVITY
ACTUALLY BECOMES. LIFE SAVING.
I'M ACTUALLY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
BILL AND I SHARED THIS WITH OUR
BUDGET HERE BECAUSE I SEE THIS
IS OUR MODERN DAY WPA IT'S A
MODERN DAY WORKS PROGRESS
ADMINISTRATION BILL IT CREATES
JOBS IT UPGRADES AND IT BUILDS
OF NEEDED INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
CONNECTIVITY FOR EVERYONE AND
IT CREATES TANGIBLE OUTCOMES
WITH ACCOUNTABILITY BUMPERS.
BECAUSE PEOPLE ALL OF US ARE
FRUSTRATED FROM LIVING IN A
MODERN TIME WHERE YOU CANNOT
HAVE CONSISTENT ACCESS TO JOBS
EDUCATION TO HEALTHCARE TO
EMERGENCY CALLS. JUST CHECKING
INTO YOUR FAMILY WITH YOUR
FAMILY AND YOUR FRIENDS. WHEN
CALIFORNIA DESERVES TO SEE THAT
WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT FIXING
BROADBAND IN TACKLING THIS
ISSUE AND I THINK THIS
CATAPULTS US INTO THE SERIOUS
CLUB LIKE NOBODY'S BUSINESS.
THE OTHER THING IS THAT YOU
KNOW THIS ISSUE IS FLUID AND I
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN HONEST ABOUT THAT AS
TECHNOLOGY AS POPULATIONS AS
CLIMATE CHANGE WE HAVE TO HAVE
A BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
IS ALSO ADAPTIVE. WHICH IS WHY
I ALSO AGREE THAT HAVING THE
CZAR AND HAVING THE COUNCIL IS
OH SO APPROPRIATE. BECAUSE IT
SHOWS THAT WHILE WE ARE MAKING
A STRONG AND DECLARATIVE
STATEMENT ABOUT BRINGING
BROADBAND TO ALL. THAT WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THIS IS THE BEGINNING
OF THIS KIND OF DISCUSSION AND
INVESTMENT AND NOT THE END SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND ONCE AGAIN THANK ALL
THAT MOVED TO GET THIS TO THE
FINISH LINE. IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE BETTER SKINNER YOU
MAY CONCLUDE. ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. BAKER FIVE
FOR JUST. I BRADFORD I HAVE A
ADAM I CORTES E. I. DALLY. I
DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN AYE
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG HI WESTOVER I PER
TANTO I JONES. I KAMLAGER I
LAYERED AYE LEYVA AYE LIMóN
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ. MAN I
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN I- CHAU OF
BOTH I PAN. I PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE I'M BURKE I WHITE
HOUSE E. AYE WIENER. I WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
HE BATES. I GROVE. MELENDEZ I
WILK HI. FIVE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO B. ASSEMBLY MEMBER INTO
CONCURRED WITH ITEM WE'RE
MOVING ON TO- FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE FIFTY FIVE ANOTHER BUDGET
ITEM ADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY BY THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT RELATING
TO CANNABIS AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. CENTER SKINNER
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU-
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS IS OUR
LAST TRAILER BILL. SB ONE SIXTY
AND IT'S THE CLEAN UP BILL FOR
AB ONE FORTY ONE THE CANNABIS
BUDGET TRAILER BILL IT INCLUDES
A ONE YEAR EXTENSION FOR OUR
LOCAL EQUITY OPERATORS TO APPLY
FOR NEW PROVISIONALS- ANNA
THREE MONTH EXTENSION FOR SMALL
CULTIVATORS. WITH LESS THAN
TWENTY THOUSAND SQUARE FEET-
THE BILL ALSO DELAYS THE
DEADLINE FOR THE- APPELLATIONS
OF ORIGIN PROGRAM TILL JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO MAKES
OTHER TECHNICAL CHANGES AND-
ASPIRO. FOR ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. CENTER
BRADFORD THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE FOLKS WHO HAVE WORKED
ON THIS ISSUE AS YOU KNOW LAST
WEEK I STOOD UP AND RAISED
CONCERNS ABOUT YOUR BILL ONE
FOUR ONE AND IN MANY WAYS THOSE
CONCERNS STILL EXIST TODAY-
WHAT I SPOKE ABOUT THE NEED FOR
REAL ADDRESSING SOCIAL EQUITY.
AND IT SHOULD BE A CONCERN FOR
ALL OF US AT FOUR OUT OF FIVE
CANNABIS BUSINESSES CURRENTLY
OPERATING UNDER A PROVISIONAL
LICENSE. BUT 100% OF OUR EQUITY.
OPERATORS ARE WORKING UNDER A
PROVISIONAL LICENSE LET ME SAY
THAT AGAIN A 100% OF EQUITY
OPERATORS ARE WORKING UNDER
PROVISIONAL LICENSE AND IT'S
NOT BECAUSE THEY'RE TRYING TO
SKIRT THE LAW. THEY WANT TO
WORK I THE LEGAL SPACE. AND
ALL EQUITY BETTER BUSINESSES.
DID YOU KNOW BUT THE BAR IS SO
INCREDIBLY HIGH FOR THEM. FILE
ON FOUR FOUR ANNUAL LICENSE
THIS WEEKEND I OPPORTUNITY
DISSIPATE INTO REDING CUTTING
OF A CANNABIS STORE IN THE
HEART. OF LA LAW CRENSHAW
BOULEVARD- THAT BY SEX. BALLING
HILLS ANGLER. THE BLACK BEVERLY
HILLS AND WHAT WAS SO
SIGNIFICANT IS THAT THIS WAS
THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN AND
FIRST FEMALE OPERATOR TO GET A
LICENSE ON CRENSHAW BOULEVARD.
THE FIRST AND SHE TOLD OF THE
STRUGGLES OF WHAT A JERK NOT
ONLY HER PARENTS BROUGHT HER
CHILDREN THREE GENERATIONS
INVOLVED IN MAKING THIS
BUSINESS SURVIVE. AND MAY NEED
TO PAY TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
A MONTH FOR OVER A YEAR. JUST
TO STAY AFLOAT WHILE WAITING
FOR THEIR LICENSE TO BE PROCESS-
THIS SHOULD TROUBLE ALL OF US
ABOUT THESE EQUITY LICENSES BUT
NOT ABLE TO FULLY ACHIEVE THEIR
FULL LICENSURE WHEN MANY WHITE
AND WEALTHY BUSINESSES CAN DO
IT. WHAT THE- NOW FOR THEIR
FINGERS MOST PEOPLE CANNOT
NAVIGATE THIS PROCESS WITHOUT
HIGH PAID CONSULTANTS AND
LAWYERS AND EVEN THEN IT TAKES
YEARS AND A LOT OF MONEY FOR
THIS TO HAPPEN. THE OUTCOME OF
THIS PROCESS CREATE. EQUITY
BUSINESSES- FOR EQUITY
BUSINESSES SHOULD BE ALARMING
TO ALL OF US- THIS TRAILER BILL-
PROVIDES EQUITY APPLICANTS WITH
THAT EXTRA YEAR TO ATTAIN A NEW
PROVISIONAL LICENSE BUT SADLY
THAT'S ALL THAT IT DOES THERE'S
NO SUPPORT FOR EXISTING EQUITY
LICENSEES. AND BACK SIMPLY DOES
NOT FLY WITH ME. I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL BUT I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO BE CLEAR
THAT THE DISCUSSION
CONVERSATION EEDS TO CONTINUE
AS IT RELATES TO EQUITY. AT THE
CORE OF THIS DISCUSSION IS IN
ABOUT A PROVISIONAL LICENSE.
AND WHO GET THEM AND HOW LONG
THEY HAVE EXPECTED TO ACHIEVE I
SHOULD SAY FOR SEQUEL
COMPLIANCE THIS IS ABOUT PEOPLE
AND COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
PERSECUTED AND PROSECUTED FOR
DECADES DURING THE WAR ON DRUGS
A WAR THAT WAS STARTED BY.
RICHARD NIXON. TO CRIMINALIZE
BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE THAT'S
WHY I WAS PUT ON THE SCHEDULE
ONE. BUT AGAIN THEY FIND THE
BIGGEST OBSTACLES IN TRYING TO
BECOME LEGAL BUSINESSES THIS IS
A CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE OF OUR
DAY. TO DAY. AND THE BUSINESS
IN OF OUR MIDDLE ISSUES AND
CANNABIS HAPPEN BE ADDRESSED
AND HAVE TO REALIZE THAT- WE
KEEP WE CANNOT CONTINUE TO MAKE
PROMISES OF THE GOVERNMENT. TO
THOSE AND- HAVE THOSE PROBLEMS
IS NOT ACHIEVED AS I SEE IT.
PROMISES AREN'T REALITY WE NEED
REALITY WHEN IT COMES TO
ADDRESSING THIS APPLICATION.
CANNABIS I RESPECT LESS RIVAL.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER. DEBATE
SINGMAN CENTER SKINNER YOU MAY
CONCLUDE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AS WE CONCLUDE THIS
TODAY'S FINAL TRAILER BILL I
WANT TO EXTEND MY GRATITUDE
NINE SURE ON BEHALF OF THE
ENTIRE SENATE THE GRATITUDE TO
OUR BUDGET STAFF AND ALL THE
OTHER STAFF WHO WORKED SO HARD
ON ALL OF THESE- ON ALL OF OUR
BUDGET ACTIONS AND OF COURSE.
THAT INCLUDES- THE
ADMINISTRATION STAFF THAT
WORKED ON THESE TWO WE KNOW
WE'LL HAVE SOME MORE THINGS TO
DO WHEN WE COME BACK FROM THIS
BREAK AND- BUT HOPEFULLY OUR
STAFF THAT HAVE WORKED SO HARD
WILL GET A LITTLE TIME OFF EVEN
THOUGH WE KNOW THEY WILL BE
WORKING OVER THE BREAK BUT I
REALLY WANT TO THANK THEM. THE
ED INCREDIBLE EFFORT AND ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE IN THIS BILL
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. BAKER ARE YOU
FOR JUST NO BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTES E. I DALLY.
NO DODD HI TORONTO. I EGGMAN
AYE GLAZER I GONZALEZ FIVE
GROVE HERTZBERG HI WESO. HI
FURTADO NO JONES NO KAMLAGER I
LAYERED. I LEYVA AYE LIMóN I
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ. NO MAN I
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN NO A CHAU
BOTH I PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH AYE RUBIO. HI SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE AMBERG AYE AYE CASKEY
AYE WIENER AYE WILK NO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES
NO. GROVE. FIVE THIRTY ONE
KNOWS EIGHT ON B. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED WITH.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIXTY EIGHT SENATOR
DRIVES ARE YOU ARE YOU READY
SHE IS MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL FIFTY ONE BY
SENATOR DORADO AN ACT RELATING
TO SURPLUS PROPERTY IN
DECLARING THE URGENCY VERA
TODAY FACT TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR EYES OF
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS SB
FIFTY ONE IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
MY COMMUNITY. WE WILL PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL COST SAVINGS FOR THE
STATE WELL PRODUCING A MODEL OF
EXPANDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND ENHANCING HOMEOWNERSHIP.
AMENDMENTS ADDED IN THE
ASSEMBLY- OF FACILITATE
HOMEOWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES
ENSURE WAY STANDARDS ON
PROJECTS AND MAKE OTHER
TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING
CHANGES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. FOR ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
DISCUSSION DEBATE SAYING NONE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
NO BACKER. ARE YOU FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I CORTES
HE I DALLY. NO DODD I DURAZO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH HERTZBERG. I HUESO ARE
YOU HER TADO I JONES NO
KAMLAGER I FLARED. ALL FIVE
LEYVA AYE LIMóN AYE MCGUIRE
AYE MELENDEZ NO MAN I NEWMAN
AYE NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF BOTH.
NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO I ROTH
AYE RUBIO I SKINNER AYE STERN.
HI I'M BURKE HI LAKE COUNTY I
WIENER AYE WILK HI. FIVE THIRTY
TWO. ON THE I. THIRTY TWO NO
SEVEN ON THE URGENCY I THIRTY
TWO NO SEVEN ON THE MEASURE.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTY NINE UP. TWENTY THREE.
SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY TWO BY
SENATOR LAYERED AN ACT RELATING
TO STATE GOVERNMENT AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY BARRACKS
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY CENTER
LETTER THE FLOOR'S YOURS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT
WHEN AMANDA RAY WAS APPOINTED
COMMISSIONER OF THE HIGHWAY
PATROL IT BECAME CLEAR THAT THE
REFERENCES IN THE STATE STATUTE
REFER TO THE COMMISSIONER AS HE
AND HIM. KNOWING THE FACT THAT
SHE MADE HISTORY AS THE FIRST
WOMAN ADDITIONALLY THERE ARE
SIMILAR PROVISIONS IN THE
CONSERVATION CORPS CODE AND THE
CODE SURROUNDING FIREFIGHTERS
IN CALIFORNIA THIS BILL WILL
UPDATE THAT CAR K. GROWING WAGE
TO ENSURE GENDER NEUTRALITY IN
THESE CODE SECTIONS IN THE
ASSEMBLY URGENCY WAS ADDED SO
THAT COULD TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY- IT HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND IT'S RECEIVE NO NO
VOTES I ASK FOR EVERYONE'S
IPHONE. THIRTY DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE IS THERE-ANY OBJECTION TO IT YOU'RE NOT
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE. FIVE
THIRTY NINE KNOWS THEY'RE ON
THE URGENCY I IS THIRTY NINE
NOTE ZERO ON THE MEASURE THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
GONNA MOVE ON TO MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION MEASURES
REPORTED FROM POLICY COMMITTEES
ON THURSDAY AND FRIDAY JULY
FIFTEENTH AND SIXTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION DO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS WILL BE GIVEN
THEIR SECOND READING AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED AND FORWARDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
REPORTED BY THE CHAIR OF THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THAT
CROSS THE DESK ON FRIDAY JULY
SIXTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WILL BE ADOPTED PUBLISHED AND
THE MEASURES RETURNED TO THE
COMMITTEE. UNDER CONSIDERATION
OF THE DAILY FILE. SECOND
READING FILE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE JOINT
RESOLUTION SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
FIFTY NINE WITH AMENDMENTS
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE THIRTY NINE
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS EIGHTY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS TO TWO TWENTY THREE
WITH AMENDMENTS TO TWENTY NINE
WITH AMENDMENTS SEVENTY SECOND
RUNNING FILE WILL DEAN WILL BE
DEEMED READ. MOVING ON TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS THERE ANY
MEMBER THAT WOULD LIKE A-
MEASURE PUT PULLED OFF THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR- REQUEST SAID AB ELEVEN
OH TWO- BE PULLED FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SO ORDERED.
SIR ANYONE ELSE. SENATOR WITH A
ARE YOU. I THINK THERE ARE
OTHER ITEMS ARE IN REGARDS TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR BOB MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
JOINT RESOLUTION FOR ASSEMBLY
JOINT RESOLUTION FIFTEEN SENATE
JOINT RESOLUTION SIX ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTIONS. ONE
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHTY TO EIGHTY
FIVE AND ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION NINETY ONE. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING THE
CONSENT- IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING UNANIMOUS CONSENT FOR
THIS ITEM. ST UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL SAYING NINE FIVE THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. ONE WE MOVE ON TO THE
SPECIAL A SPECIAL CONTRACT
NUMBER OKAY OKAY GREAT. OKAY.
BIONDA COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENT
SENATOR PORTANTINO. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WILL MEET AT
TWELVE O'CLOCK IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- TWO. FORTY ZERO THREE TWO.
VERY GOOD S. SENATE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE AT NOON. IF THERE IS NO
OTHER BUSINESS. SENATE RECKONS
THIS IS CLEAR THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES LET ME
JUST START THANK YOU AS WE
CONCLUDE AND GET READY FOR OUR
LEGISLATIVE RECESS WERE WE GO
HOME TO OUR DISTRICTS. AND WE
WORK THERE AND WE SPEND TIME
WITH OUR FAMILIES I'M GOING TO
HOPE THAT YOU TAKE A LITTLE
TIME TO GET SOME REST BECAUSE
THIS IS BEEN AN INCREDIBLY BUSY
TOM THIS LAST WEEK ALONE WAS
BUSIER THAN PREVIOUS WEEK SO-
THE POLICY COMMITTEES OF THOSE
THAT MET UNTIL MIDNIGHT AND
CAME AND THE NEXT DAY AND MET
ALL DAY- TO YOUR STAFF TO THE
POLICY COMMITTEE STAFF TO THE
BUDGET CHAIRED THE BUDGET SUBS
THE STAFF. TO ARE INCREDIBLE US
SECRETARY TO ALL OF THE FLOOR
STAFF ARE WE WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THIS WORK I HOPE THAT YOU
FEEL THAT YOU HAVE DONE THE
PEOPLE'S BUSINESS THESE LAST
FEW WEEKS EVEN AS PEOPLE STILL
STRUGGLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES I
HOPE YOU AT LEAST GET A SENSE
THAT. WE ARE TRYING TO DO WHAT
WE NEED TO DO FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS ACROSS THE STATE
AND SO I HOPE YOU GO HOME WITH
A LITTLE BIT OF PRIDE IN HAVING
DONE THE PEOPLE'S BUSINESS EVEN
AS WE HAVE MORE WORK TO DO WHEN
WE RETURN AND WE KNOW THAT SO
WITH THAT EVERYONE COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU I WILL MISS YOU. BUT
I WILL BE GLAD THAT WE GET TO
HAVE A BREAK- SO OUR NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY
AUGUST SIXTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AT TWO PM BE SAFE. AND BE
WELL. THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY. AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE PLACED WE WILL
RECONVENE MONDAY AUGUST
SIXTEENTH AT TWO PM. ENJOY YOUR
TIME AT HOME FOLKS.